Lull.
So, mal gucken, ob es das jetzt gecheckt hat.
Ja, sieht gut aus.
Pause Champ.
Ah, ein bisschen viel hier.
Bisschen viel des Guten.
Weeps in.
Übrigens, wir müssen was ausprobieren.
Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht gut.
Deswegen, ich werde es wahrscheinlich gleich wieder ausmachen.
Ich habe heute mein anderes Mikrofon dran.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den Unterschied hört.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, ihr hört den Unterschied.
Im Mikrofon.
Wenn ich die Musik nicht so laut mache.
Ich denke mal, ihr hört den Unterschied.
Im Sound.
Die Sache ist bloß die.
Das Problem ist nur.
Ich habe keinen gescheiten Aufbau für mein normales Aufnahmemikrofon.
Das heißt, ich wollte jetzt einfach nur mal testen, ob sich das wirklich lohnt.
Also Leute, hört sich das heute?
Viel besser an als sonst.
Mit dem Mikrofon.
Also ich überlege gerade, ob das das wert ist, das Setup hier irgendwie umzustellen, weil das Mikrofon steht jetzt vor mir auf dem Schreibtisch.
Also sprich, ich habe mein Headset ganz normal auf, wie sonst, dass ich mich selbst höre, aber ich habe halt zum Aufnehmen jetzt mein Mikrofon davor.
Das Mikrofon hier, also das, was ich jetzt hier vor mir stehen habe, hat schon eine bessere Quali als das Headset.
Das Problem ist nur, dass ich da halt aktualisieren kann.
Ich habe aktuell kein gescheites, kein gescheites Setup für habe.
Ja, das steht auf dem Schreibtisch, das sagt das.
Also das werde ich gleich wieder ausmachen, weil guckt das Problem, wenn Mikrofone auf dem Schreibtisch stehen, ist zum Beispiel das hier.
Also ihr hört jetzt wirklich, wenn ich fest im Maustaster hau.
Hört ihr, hört ihr, das, das, das, das Gehau, ja.
Dafür kann ich jetzt POC-ASMR-Content machen, genau.
Ich kann euch jetzt, ich kann euch Twitch-Emojis vorflüstern.
Huge ASMR-Content, Alter.
Als nächstes gibt es da noch mehr.
Pool-Streams.
POC-AS, Alter.
POC-AS.
Huge POC.
Ne, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Ist der Discord-Bot kaputt?
Das ist eine exzellente Frage.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Kannst du direkt einen Vergleich zeigen?
Ja.
Moment.
Wir vergleichen mal die Mikrofone direkt.
Also das ist jetzt hier mein normales Mikrofon.
Also das, was ihr jetzt hört, das ist das normale Mikrofon.
Das habe ich auch immer dran, wenn ich Videos aufnehme.
Das Dumme ist.
Ich habe dafür kein gescheites Streaming-Setup, ne.
Ich habe zwar hier.
Ich hätte theoretisch einen Monitor, äh, ich kann fast labern, einen Monitor standen,
ein Mikrofon standen.
Ich könnte das auch so hinbauen, dass das gut funktioniert.
Habe ich jetzt aber nicht gemacht.
Ich habe es einfach nur vor mir stehen, weil ich mal wissen wollte, wie die Soundqualität
ist, ne.
Das Dumme ist halt, ihr hört jetzt, wenn ich hier tippe und so.
Das sackt ein bisschen.
So, jetzt machen wir mal direkt einen Vergleich von den Mikros mit dem bisherigen.
Theoretisch muss ich es einfach nur rausziehen und dann die Lautstärke anpassen.
Probieren wir es mal aus.
Mal gucken, ob ich jetzt, mal gucken, ob ich jetzt, ja, ne, nicht neues Mikrofon.
Ich habe jetzt das Aufnahmemikrofon dran.
Das ganz normale Mikrofon, mit dem ich es aufnehme.
So, ich ziehe das jetzt mal raus.
Max, was sagst du eigentlich zu Mr.
Hank?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Wer ist das?
Sagt mir gar nichts.
So Leute, also Achtung.
Ich ziehe jetzt mal das Mikrofon raus und dann passe ich die Lautstärke an und dann
solltet ihr das Alte wieder hören.
Aha.
So, das ist jetzt das Alte.
So.
Das ist jetzt das Alte.
Das ist jetzt das Alte, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass der Mr.
Hanky war dein größter Hater.
Hä?
Jetzt siehst du mal, der kann nicht so viel gehatet haben.
Ich habe da kaum was von mitbekommen.
Lohnt sich nicht zu wechseln.
Das Alte klingt ein bisschen schlechter.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das, das, das ist so.
Ist halt auch ein Headset-Mikro.
Warte mal, was hat denn der hier jetzt eingestellt?
89.
89 ist fast ein bisschen laut, ne?
Und, ne, wobei.
Ja, 71 hatte ich sonst immer, aber mit dem Unterschied, ich habe sonst immer Filter drin
gehabt.
Ich habe hier den Gain hochgemacht und da 71.
Jetzt machen wir mal exakt die gleichen Settings, wie ich sonst immer hatte.
So, 71.
Das ist jetzt ein Ticken zu leise.
Ne, das ist jetzt ein Ticken zu leise.
Schauen wir mal Gain an.
So.
Und jetzt ist der Sound, jetzt ist der Sound exakt so, wie ich ihn sonst immer hatte.
Ja, ich muss mal gucken.
Dann lasse ich es jetzt erstmal so.
Dann lasse ich es jetzt erstmal so, wie gehabt.
Wie viel hat das neue gekostet?
Keine Ahnung, das habe ich schon 5 Jahre oder so.
Das nehme ich ja, das Mikro, was ich eben dran hatte, das habe ich ja sonst auch immer, wenn ich Videos aufnehme.
Ja.
Übrigens, Leute.
Gestern, ich habe gestern die Bitrate gar nicht hochgestellt.
Und dafür sah das Game echt relativ gut aus.
Ich habe mit 4,9 Mbit gestreamt.
Aber gut, das sind Half-Life, Half-Life 1 Graphics, ne?
Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich das, das ist ja kein neues Mikrofon.
Das ist mein ganz normales Blue Yeti, was ich seit 5 Jahren oder so da habe.
Ja, das Headset produziert Plop-Geräusche, das stimmt.
Da ist zwar ein Plop-Shot drauf, aber da kannst du nicht, leider nicht allzu viel machen.
Ich meine, ich könnte, ich könnte, ich könnte das Headset weiter weg machen, ja.
Aber, aber das hört sich halt einfach dumm an, wenn ich das Headset weiter weg habe.
Ja.
Wartet mal, ich muss mir das mal kurz, ich muss mir das mal kurz selbst anhören.
Warte mal, wie ging das hier nochmal?
Advanced.
Keg Wait.
Naja, also so höre ich mich doch schon ein bisschen weiter weg an, ne?
Ich meine, so, so müsste doch eigentlich schon besser sein.
Ich höre, ich höre das ja auch bei mir auf dem Ohr, dass sich so besser anhört.
Ich finde halt nur, dass ich, ich klinge so aggressiv in Streams immer.
Über das Mikro.
Über die, über das Headset-Mikro.
Ich finde, es hört sich viel älter an.
Ja.
Es hört sich viel entspannter an und viel neutraler in YouTube, in den YouTube-Videos.
Du klingst immer aggressiv, ernsthaft?
Das Headset hört sich greller an, ja.
Ja, ja, genau, genau.
Ich meine, man kann da sicherlich auch ein bisschen hier irgendwie, ich mache mal kurz den Kompressor einfach mal aus.
Einfach Kompressor stellst aus.
Oh, das ist viel zu leise.
Guck mal.
Das hört sich jetzt, das hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ziemlich platt an.
Ähm, das Headset ist vermutlich dynamisch, das Mikrofon vermutlich ein Content.
Ja, genau, so sieht es aus.
Ich dachte, du bist aggressiv.
Nee, das, ich, nee, Leute, ich meine das jetzt ernsthaft.
Das hört sich so, so, so gestresst immer an, wenn ich, wenn ich irgendwie ins Mikro dabei bin.
Stimmt das überhaupt nicht?
Null.
Ja.
So.
Vielleicht muss ich noch ein bisschen einmal, vielleicht mache ich einfach mal RTX Voice an.
Mal ausprobieren damit.
Ja, gut.
Okay, Leute.
Also, dann würde ich sagen, wir spielen das jetzt mal fertig.
Also, Plan für heute ist von.
Ups.
Dankeschön.
STBA für den Sub.
16 Monate.
Jetzt habe ich gerade passend Schluckauf.
Perfekt.
Perfekter Einstieg.
Hyper Subscription hier.
Max, was sagst du zur aktuellen Grafikkartengeneration?
Ähm, äh, Situation?
Ich sag dazu, du solltest täglich den Preisschamp checken, wo es was gibt und feststellen, dass es nichts gibt.
Und wenn, dann das Doppelte vom UVP.
Okay, soll ich mir mal das Hatervideo angucken?
Also, das, das ist angeblich mein größter Hater.
Ja, der kann ja nicht so, der kann ja nicht so krass haten, oder?
Der kann ja nicht so krass haten, wenn er zuletzt vor neun Jahren was gemacht hat.
Krasser Hater.
Massive.
Ich kenne nur noch den Typ, ich hatte mal so ein Kind, das auch übelst rum gehatet hat vor zehn Jahren.
Und der hat dann bei sich auf dem Channel irgendwie nen Joint geraucht oder so.
Und das haben dann die Leute reported und dann wurde sein Channel gesperrt.
Haha.
Das kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Kickmate.
Irgend so ein Zwölfjähriger.
Haha.
Das war so geil, Alter.
Irgendein Zwölf-, ich weiß ja, der hat übelst rum gehatet.
Irgendein, es war irgendein Zwölf-, Dreizehnjähriger.
Und dann bin ich bei ihm auf dem Channel gewesen, hab geguckt, da hat er irgendein Joint geraucht.
Das hab ich dann mal im Video erwähnt.
Und ich hab nicht gesagt, Leute, geht hin und, und, und reported oder so.
Aber die Leute haben es natürlich gefunden, das Fressen, ja.
Haha.
Ja.
So.
Äh, kurz Chat gucken.
Ja.
Das, danach machen wir, danach machen wir, äh, Stellenanzeigen raussuchen.
Falls derjenige am Start ist, der mir diese, ähm, Infrastructure, diese Piraten, diese
Piraten-Stellenanzeige gepostet hat, der kann, kann er die Blitz nochmal posten, weil, die
will ich ins nächste Video reinnehmen.
Ansonsten muss ich ihm...
Ach, da ist er doch.
Excellent.
Genau.
Infrar-Structure-Engineer gesucht.
Das wollte ich mit reinnehmen ins nächste Video.
Ein Teil unserer Crew beim letzten All-Hook on Deck.
Oh, das ist so cringe.
Hahaha.
Oh, Mann.
Das ist so cringe, Alter.
Hast du auch gelesen?
Ja, aber ich hab da noch kein Witt drüber gemacht.
Ich mach jetzt ein Witt drüber.
Die nächsten Tage.
Okay, Leute.
Ich würd sagen, auf geht's.
Spielen wir das mal durch.
Ich weiß nicht, wie lang es geht.
Allzu lang kann das Ganze, by the way, nicht mehr funktionieren.
Äh, nicht mehr.
Ich laber manchmal einen Blödsinn, Alter.
Allzu lange kann das Ganze nicht mehr gehen, denn, ähm, oh, wir kommen noch gar nicht zurück.
Denn, wir sind schon bestimmt drei Stunden oder so am Start und das Spiel geht angeblich
nur drei bis vier Stunden.
Oh, Schreck.
Moment.
Oh.
Schreck.
Moment.
Ich lade jetzt mal neu, dass wir...
What?
Ah, yes.
Okay, dann fangen wir an.
Erstmal schön nachladen und danach...
Also ich wollte ja nochmal eins sagen, bevor wir anfangen.
Also, jetzt erstmal spielen wir Echoes, durchspielen.
Das ist in Punkt eins heute.
Dann machen wir kurz Af-Klo-Pause.
Dann machen wir Stellenanzeigenvorbereitung für Wit.
Vorbereitung für Wit equativ.
als RAR
verpacken. Das war
peckschamp. Das war change.
Ich hoffe, die machen hier das. Ich hoffe, das ist hier ihr
Daily, Daily Stand-Up
Scrum Kanban
Tribe Meeting.
Das kommt auch noch irgendwann, Leute.
Ich sag's euch. Dieses ganze agile
Zeug, was es jetzt gibt,
irgendwann kommt dann einer, der macht dann
Meta-Agile und der nimmt
dann quasi alle Sachen und macht da
so ein Daily-Programm draus.
Also du machst dann nicht nur Kanban-Boards,
du machst dann nicht nur Daily-Scrum,
du machst dann nicht nur Tribe und Dings
und sonst was Meeting. Du machst das dann
alles in einem. Das ist dann der nächste
Agile-Shit.
Hast dann 8 Stunden Programm. Hey,
guck dir mal die ganzen
Videos an
auf YouTube. So ist
der Job eines Software-Engineers.
Diese ganzen Videos,
die kommen auf die Arbeit, dann
fordern sie erstmal eine Banane,
dann machen sie sich einen Kaffee, dann
labern sie eine Runde, da spielen sie eine Runde
Tischkicker, dann setzen sie sich mal kurz
an den Rechner und checken ihre Mails,
dann spielen sie eine Runde Xbox, dann
gehen sie in die Kantine Mittagessen,
dann gehen sie in die Kantine
Mittagessen, dann machen sie irgendwie
das Daily-Meeting, dann setzen sie sich nochmal
kurz an den Rechner und programmieren 20 Minuten,
dann gehen sie ins Fitnessstudio,
was in dem Dings ist, und dann gehen
sie dann um 22 Uhr, kommen sie
heim und haben am Tag 20 Minuten programmiert.
Easy.
Realität pur.
Ganz normaler Tag.
So, irgendwie ist heute,
irgendwie liegt mir mein Headset-Kabel im Weg
heute. Was ist denn da los?
Was soll das denn? Das liegt sonst nie im Weg.
Wenn es nur so wäre.
Tja, tja, ist so.
Leider
ist die Realität und das,
wie die das in solchen Videos
darstellen, halt oftmals
bisschen
auseinander.
Was agile Jobs
so was gibt es? Ernsthaft?
Privacy-Error. Wait a minute.
Was ist das für eine Seite? Da gehe ich
schnell drauf. Keine Chance
hier. Keine Chance.
Okay, auf geht's, Leute.
Jetzt aber. Jetzt werden sie
weggeschneibt.
Huge.
Irgendwie.
Wie?
Huge AI.
Huge Massive AI
haben wir da. Wisst ihr, was wir
jetzt machen, Leute? Achtung, diese
komischen Dinger brauchen wir sonst eh nicht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Lässt mich in Ruhe.
Jetzt habe ich jetzt ziemlich dumm geworfen, das Teil.
Heiß.
Schreck. Okay.
Alter. Moment.
Ich muss neu laden. Ich bin zu dumm. Ich bin zu dumm,
diese Waffen zu verwenden.
Ist ja echt krass.
Man sollte eigentlich annehmen, ein Spiel, was ich
gespielt habe, seit ich 16 bin
oder so, bin ich irgendwie,
bin ich irgendwie in der Lage, sinnvoll zu bedienen.
Aber es ist gerade echt nicht, nicht, nicht,
nicht so gemeint.
Half-Life Pro confirmed.
Jetzt aber.
Wunderbar.
Exquisite.
Guck her. Jetzt wird er
aufgefressen.
Wie? Das ist wieder auf mich drauf.
Okay, da oben waren noch so fette
Dinger. Die werden wir jetzt einfach in die Luft sprengen.
Pass mal auf. Und...
Bam! Richtig
zerfetzt sind sie.
Da kommt der Boomer
zum Vorschein. Ist so.
Ich find's ja gut, dass die mit sich selbst
kämpfen.
Da muss ich nichts machen.
Hör auf. Die kriegen jetzt Shotgun. Shotgun
ins Gesicht.
Bam! Das war ziemlich
pepega, da ich da jetzt einfach rausgejumpt bin.
Massive pepega.
Aber die Dinger können
nix.
Die Dinger können gar nix.
Was in dem Mod sehr merkwürdig ist,
die haben die MP5.
Die haben die MP5
ziemlich genervt. Die trifft kaum noch was.
Na, guck mal.
Guck mal, wie die rumschießt.
Triffst du gar nix.
Okay, nice.
Oh, was ist das?
Ah.
Wetten? Das ist natürlich...
Also, manchmal
muss ich ja sagen, manchmal sind die Gegner
echt dumm, ne?
Ich mein,
ich hab da nen Osprey hingestellt.
Der fliegt da rum, macht nix.
Und genau darauf ausgerichtet
hab ich so ne Kanone,
die den jetzt wahrscheinlich abschießen wird.
Oh, cute.
Mehr Revolution als Battlefield 4, Leute.
Oh, was jetzt?
Geht das jetzt hinter mir auf?
Da.
Keck, wait.
Wo soll ich denn wissen, dass es da jetzt
explodiert?
Haben wir es jetzt?
Geh mal kurz Loot.
Kurz mal Loot abchecken.
Hier ist nix.
Was die wirklich gut gemacht haben,
was mir sehr gut gefällt,
dass das hier der Anfang ist.
Also sprich, gerade wo wir hier rumlaufen,
ist genau das, wo wir am Anfang schon mal durchgelaufen sind.
Ich mag so Mods.
Also ich mag nicht notorisches Backtracking oder so.
Das find ich nervig.
Aber was ich mag, ist, wenn es so Wiedererkennungssachen hat.
Ich mochte es auch im originalen Half-Life.
Kann es sein, dass die Soundeffekte
mega laut...
Stimmt?
Ist das zu laut, Leute?
Ne.
Passt eigentlich.
Eigentlich gut eingestellt.
Was ist die Mod?
Das ist quasi die Half-Life-Story,
diesmal aus Sicht von einem Wissenschaftler in Black Mesa.
Wir haben aber gestern schon das zum größten Teil durchgespielt.
Was die übrigens nicht erklären, ist,
warum der Wissenschaftler so der geile Shooterman ist
und alles ownen kann.
Weil, ich mein, als Wissenschaftler ist man jetzt normalerweise
mit so einem M4 oder mit so einem M16
und Pistolen jetzt nicht unbedingt
so gut.
Also.
So, was haben wir denn hier am Start?
Minen?
Kleinteile, Zeugs?
MP5.
Immer MP5.
By the way, es sieht aus wie eine M16,
aber es ist laut Half-Life-Story.
Eine MP5.
Was hier, Leute?
Wow!
Panzer!
Der Panzer ist am Start!
Ja, die Soundeffekte sind schon ganz schön laut, oder?
Das schreit einem ganz schön ins Ohr, der Typ.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Soundeffekt oder Soundvolume...
Ist angenehm.
Ja, klar.
Okay, seh ich das richtig?
Das ist die übliche Geschichte.
Es ist die übliche Geschichte.
Ähm.
Da ist ein Panzer
und ich kriege jetzt einen Raketenwerfer.
Lull.
Immer der gleiche Kram.
Die Logik, ne?
Die Logik werd's mir nie erschließen.
Warum zufälligerweise immer eine Granatwerfer...
einen Raketenwerfer-Rumblick, wenn man einen braucht.
Mach ich einfach mal ein bisschen
Strafe-Action in der Hoffnung, dass...
Nee, der ist nicht down.
Mach ich das nicht...
Oh, fuck, Mann!
Wie, warum ist der nicht down?
Ah, da oben sind noch mehr.
Hier ist noch mehr.
Nachschub.
Alter, lass mich in Ruhe, Panzer.
Der ist aber ordentlich stabil.
Jetzt aber.
Immer noch nicht.
WTF?
Was hält denn das...
Was hält denn das Teil aus?
Okay.
Renn, Gordon!
Renn!
Renn, hier ist noch was.
Nein, Panzer, du bist...
Panzer, du bist zu langsam.
Boah!
Okay, vielleicht müssen wir von hinten drauf schießen.
Wir müssen von hinten drauf schießen.
Ah!
Ah, natürlich.
Alles klar.
In den Bobbes, genau.
Muss ich bestimmt aufpassen, dass ich nicht airstriked werde.
Guckt euch mal an.
Massive Textur.
Einfach...
Poor girl.
Oh!
Zack, zack, zack, zack, zack.
Wir machen das jetzt anders.
Wir machen Stelz...
Stelz-Action.
Achtung.
Ne, wir machen keine Stelz-Action.
Wir nehmen einfach die letzte Rakete.
So, haben wir den ersten gerippt schon mal.
Und jetzt...
Bam!
In den Kopf.
Bam, voll rein.
Ich snipe die jetzt einfach.
Zack.
Einen haben wir noch.
Einen haben wir noch, oder?
Oh, wir haben noch einen.
Einen haben wir noch.
Einen haben wir noch, oder?
Oh, wir haben sogar noch zwei.
Zack.
Schreckt.
Genau.
Der letzte kriegt einen Revolver in den Kopf.
Na gut, es war kein Revolver im Kopf.
Es war...
Fuck you, Last Stand.
Oh!
Pass mal auf Shotgun.
Ich glaube, da hat die KI gerade ein bisschen ausgesetzt.
Bei der Armbrust ist auch ein Delay da.
Armbrust ist halt...
Der Pfeil fliegt halt.
So, mal kurz reloaden.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass wir jetzt hier durch müssen.
Nein, müssen wir nicht.
Oh!
Leute, da ist noch ein Panzer.
Ich habe keine Muni mehr.
Kommst du her?
Oh, Moment.
She baited.
Massive she bait.
Komm her.
Das macht immer Bock.
Richtig rein gebaited.
Six Head.
Six Head bait.
Kommen wir da?
Muni.
Deben.
Exzellent.
Ah, sch Gillrote Fessah.
Es ist auch immer wieder erstaunlich, dass...
Okay.
dass in so ziemlich jeder Forschungseinrichtung
an jeder Ecke
hochexplosive rote Fässer
stehen. Wo sind die eigentlich
real life? Leute, ich fahre im echten Leben,
ich fahre jeden Tag am Südbahnhof
in Frankfurt vorbei, da sind ganz,
also am Ostbahnhof in Frankfurt davor, da sind
ganz viele Container
und ich habe noch nicht ein rotes Fass gesehen,
was dann explodiert ist.
Muss mal welche
platzieren, ich glaube, das ist illegal.
Anele, genau.
Und
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
gehst du fort?
Gehst du weg?
Wo muss ich denn jetzt hin?
Da ist ein Panzer.
Moment, ich muss dem Panzer
das Ding abschießen lassen, Leute, 100 pro.
Massive evade.
Massive evading.
Pass mal auf hier.
Oder auch nicht.
Ne.
Äh, okay.
Okay, Game, was willst du ver...
Da ist grün, da muss ich hin.
Man muss immer da hin, wo grün ist.
Das haben die in dem Game gut gemacht.
Da, wo grün ist, geht's lang.
Außerdem war hier vorher...
Oh, ich glaube, ich muss hier oben lang.
Bleibst du weg?
Gehst du weg? Fisch, bleib weg.
Loch.
Oh, neue Waffe. Neue Weapon.
Weapons.
Neue Weapons.
Und jetzt wird er, jetzt wird er gelasert.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, damit kann man
kaputt machen.
Jetzt schreckt, Alter.
Ich habe die Hälfte meiner Leben
verloren, aber das war es wert.
Safe.
Alter, war das laut.
Ja, habe ich das Game irgendwie...
Ist das lauter als gestern?
Sollte eigentlich nicht sein, ne?
Bin da auf Easy Clap.
Also...
Kannst du noch ein Stückchen
leiser machen, das Ganze?
Oh.
Was jetzt? Leute, ich brauche Leben.
Ich kann jetzt nicht weiter fighten.
Ich brauche Massive Life.
Ich bin stuck.
Ich bin fucking stuck.
Na geil.
Good Job, Mord. Good Job.
Okay, wo kriege ich jetzt noch mein Leben her?
Hier ist zu. Okay, hier geht es nicht weiter.
Hier, Life, Life. Exquisite.
Jetzt spawnen Hunde.
Zack, down. Oh.
Squid.
Jetzt ist es ja gut.
Jetzt ist es...
Okay, die Dinger snipen wir.
Oh, shit.
Geh weg, geh weg.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Das sind diese Kackdinger.
Sind die unverwundbar?
Ne.
Die Dinger haben mich auch im Original Half-Life
mega abgefuckt.
Okay.
Nice.
Force Champ?
Wie, bin ich jetzt verreckt in der Cutscene?
Ah, ne.
Okay, alles gut.
Alles gut.
Wenn Cutscene erstmal gestartet ist, kann einem ja nichts mehr passieren.
Diagonal agil.
Nein, man ist nicht diagonal agil.
Man skaliert diagonal.
Das muss man schon richtig benutzen hier.
Confused.
What?
Aha.
Very good.
We'll take it from here.
Prepare for unforeseen.
Consequences.
Was ist jetzt der Anfall von Half-Life?
What?
I should have known when he rescued her.
It was for his own damn reasons.
Was zum...
Well, well.
Isn't this just like
old times?
We've been rather busy
in your absence, Mr. Freeman.
That will be all.
Gordon?
What is...
Was zum...
Okay.
An alle krassen Half-Life-Lore-Story-Kenner.
Was genau möchte mir das Spiel sagen?
Was genau ist los?
War das das...
Ich meine, es war Gordon am Start.
Es war Alex am Start.
Der G-Man war am Start.
Der Vater von Alex war am Start.
Das heißt, im Endeffekt,
das muss von der Timeline
jetzt eigentlich
zu Episode 2
oder so sein?
Was?
Hä?
Okay, ich muss nicht alles verstehen.
Easy mod, easy live.
Kann man hier
Trick 17 machen?
Ah, Prick plus nix.
Alles verstanden, easy. Obvious.
Komplett klar, was passiert.
Bin ich denn jetzt überhaupt was?
Ich habe auch keine Waffen mehr und sonst was.
Ich kann mir nur noch vorstellen, was morgen passiert.
Erstmal Licht anmachen.
Wir treffen uns.
Was?
Es ist so schön, dich mit uns zu haben.
Oh.
Nicht lange.
Alter, was geht jetzt?
Okay, ich habe legit absolut keinen
Plassen Schimmer, was passiert.
Ich sehe nur, dass das richtig Poggers Kinderspielzeug hat.
Mit diesem, mit diesem
Kistenträger von Black Mesa.
Was passiert? Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Da liegen, da liegen,
da liegen einfach Leichen im Kleiderschrank.
Ob das alles
Kanon ist, das ist ein Mod, das kann nicht Kanon sein.
Aber er versucht ja
zumindest irgendwie
da drauf Bezug zu nehmen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich habe legit keinen Schimmer.
Okay, der G-Man hat das Ding
gereckt.
Not this
time.
Pay attention.
I'm only going to say this
once.
Prepare for unforeseen
consequences.
Was?
Alarm, Alarm.
Leute,
ich habe null Plan, was
ansatzweise abgeht, aber
er hat sich echt Mühe gegeben beim Inszenieren.
Ah, fertig.
Alles klar.
Okay, das hätten wir gestern auch durchspielen können.
Das hat ja nur eine Viertelstunde länger gedauert.
Das hätten wir gestern auch durchspielen können.
Easy.
Okay, okay,
Fazit, Fazit.
Optisch auf jeden Fall
eines der besten
Goldsauce Half-Life 1 Mods
überhaupt.
Also ich denke mal, dass jetzt vorbei ist.
Ähm.
An sich war der Mod echt gut.
Kannste nix sagen.
Drei Stunden, dreieinhalb Stunden.
Drei bis vier Stunden.
Wir waren ein bisschen lahm teilweise.
Vier Stunden ziemlich klassischer
Half-Life-Stells.
Und
was, was.
Ich muss sagen, das Beste war echt
so die
ersten zwei Drittel.
Wo du noch
auf Munition und sowas achten musstest.
Das letzte Drittel war halt typisches
Bäm bä bä bäm.
Die Story war nicht wirklich nachvollziehbar.
Ich muss aber auch sagen, ich habe keinen Plan
von einer Half-Life-Story nach so vielen Jahren noch.
Ähm.
Ja.
Aber ich fand den Mod echt nice.
Kann ich jedem empfehlen
zu spielen.
Hat echt Bock gemacht.
Aber ich bin eh Half-Life-Fanboy.
Also ich mein, ich hab die Story soweit kapiert
bis zum Schluss.
Ne? Also.
Es war so.
Das lief parallel zu den Events von
Half-Life 1.
Sie haben es ein bisschen verpasst, dass man mal irgendwie
Freeman sieht oder so. Aber okay.
Es lief parallel zu den Events von Half-Life 1.
Und
du warst halt
dabei als Wissenschaftler.
So. Was die uns jetzt
am Schluss damit sagen
wollten, mit
Gordon
und irgendwie
einem Baby und dem G-Man und
ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab ernsthaft absolut
keine Ahnung. Da müssen wir mal gleich googeln
danach. Half-Life Echoes
äh
Ending. Explained
oder so.
Weil da bin ich zu
da bin ich zu low-brain für.
Gordon plus Alex
gleich Baby? Ne, oder?
Das ist glaube ich ein bisschen
zu weit interpretiert so.
Die Bumsen. Der Chat
Gachibas, alles klar. Der Chat
hat's wieder out-gefigert hier.
Der Chat weiß wieder Bescheid.
Kommt noch was?
Post-Champ? Nein.
Okay, das war's. Echt geiler Mod.
Ähm, die Frage ist okay.
Half-Life Echoes.
Ending. Explained.
Half-Life Echoes
Proposition. Was ist denn, was heißt
dann Proposition? Zusammenfassung
oder, oder was?
Äh, G-Man.
Vorschlag.
Ja, stimmt. Das heißt
wirklich Vorschlag, ja.
Proposal dachte ich ist Vorschlag, aber
äh, Propos...
Aussatz. Ah, doch. Doch, doch, doch.
Also, ach, ah. So quasi die, die, die
Essenz aus dem Ganzen, so.
Die Aussage. Die Aussage.
Okay, zeigt mal her. Jetzt, jetzt
lassen wir uns mal erklären, was uns das Ganze sagen, sagen
sollte.
Ach nee, doch nicht. Okay.
Ending.
In Half-Life... What the hell is going
on? Exakt, genau das
denke ich mir auch. Okay.
Ähm. Okay, man hat kein...
Es hat keiner nen Plan.
Es hat im Prinzip keiner nen Plan.
Okay.
Dass das ein, dass das ein gecutted enemy
aus Half-Life 1 war, das hab ich auch schon gecheckt.
What?
Chat, das ist jetzt aber
echt fast dredged.
Der Chat ist der Meinung,
dass...
die Leiche hier im
Wandschrank ist die Mutter
von Alex.
But why?
Warum?
Wie soll man da drauf kommen?
Ich check's nicht. Nee, das ist mir
zu... Da bin ich zu low IQ
für, glaube ich, um das Ende zu verstehen. Aber
das macht ja nix. Man muss
sich alles verstehen.
Two-three hat, Leute.
Two-three hat.
Gut, dann stellen wir mal um, würde ich sagen.
Machen wir erst mal DNA-Analyse, genau.
So, dann stellen wir mal um.
Von
Retro
nach
Just Chatting
Stellenanzeigen mit
Peter Agile.
Video
Vorberei... Ist Video-Vorbereitung
ein Wort?
Video-Vorbereitung
wahrscheinlich.
So, machen wir mal einen neuen Titel. Zack.
Exquisite.
Wenn ich
sicher einfach bin. Stimmt, das
geht immer. So, hat's den Titel angepasst?
Zeig her.
Nein.
Warte. Also...
Achso, danach, Moment, Moment.
Danach muss weg.
Okay, perfekt. Wunderbar.
Also.
Sehr nice. Also, nicer Mod.
Kann man echt empfehlen zu spielen. Ende hab ich
nicht gecheckt. Ende war mir wirklich
zu massive brain.
Kennst du diese Studiere
jetzt Lehramt Informatik YouTube Video
Werbung? Nee.
Ich kenn aber einen, der Lehr... der Lehramt
studiert. Den kennt ihr auch.
Wir haben ihn schon eine Weile nicht
mehr im Chat gesehen.
Genau der.
Die Story war nicht nachvollziehbar.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wo ist der Cute Mod?
Tja, entweder, also es gibt zwei Varianten.
Entweder muss der Cute Mod lernen und hat
keine Zeit. Oder
der Cute Mod versucht immer noch das
Lehramtsgrill von sich zu überzeugen und
es hat geklappt und deswegen hat er keine Zeit.
Man weiß es nicht. Man weiß es nicht.
Die werden dringend gesucht. Es werden sowohl
Informatiker als auch Lehrer
gesucht. Wobei ich halt keinen Bock hätte
ehrlich gesagt Lehrer zu werden.
Sag ich euch wie es ist.
Mir gehen normale Menschen schon extrem auf den
Sack. Wie ist das dann, wie ist
das erst mit Schülern?
Schüler sind ja noch nerviger.
Ich weiß wie ich als Schüler war.
Und ich hätte wirklich keinen Bock auf Schüler.
Ja, ist echt
so. Schüler sind nervig.
Und Lehrer, Lehrer würde
ich im Leben nicht werden wollen. Lehrer ist eines der
schlimmsten Berufe überhaupt.
Das kannst du glaube ich.
Ich glaube du kannst Lehrer gar nicht 30 Jahre
machen ohne komplett verrückt zu werden.
Das ist nicht im
Scope. Dass
Schüler nervig sind kann ich vollkommen zustimmen.
Ja, siehste.
Ist so. Schüler
sind massive nervig.
So, ich habe gesagt Leute
nachdem wir mit Echoes durchgespielt haben,
muss ich eine kurze Pause machen.
Deswegen gehe ich
jetzt mal schnell auf Klo.
Und ich überlege gerade was ich im
Hintergrund laufen lasse.
Ich mache einfach Werbung für mein aktuelles Video.
Keck wait.
Ne, ich lasse den Chat auf.
Mach Pippe Dance an und ich gehe jetzt mal kurz aufs Klo.
Ich bin in 2-3 Minuten
wieder da.
Schau mal hier.
Afg Klo.
Bam.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da.
So, da bin ich wieder.
Afg Klo ist beendet.
Hoch,
was ist denn hier los?
Warum ist da ein anderes Emote als
als wir, als ich weggegangen bin?
War der Chat das?
Wer war das von euch Chat?
Der Chat war in, habe ich gesehen.
Was?
Ne, das kann nicht sein.
Meint ihr ich war das wirklich selbst?
Ne, wie kommt ihr denn auf
solche Sachen?
Sowas würde ich doch nicht machen.
Ich debate euch doch nicht vom Klo aus.
Reveal!
Ich war es tatsächlich selbst.
Ich weiß, kommt jetzt unerwartet.
Hätte keiner mit gerechnet.
Massive.
Ja.
Okay, auf geht's. Also.
Welche Seiten gucken wir nochmal?
Golem Jobs.
Was zum?
Golem Jobs, Alter.
Das ist aber verrutscht auf der Reihe
von der Tastatur.
Golem Jobs gucke ich immer gerne.
Weil
da sind immer so richtig Crap Anzeigen.
So, nochmal StepStone
können wir noch gucken.
Übrigens wisst ihr was geil ist?
Mein LinkedIn
Peter Aguilera
Mein LinkedIn Account gibt es immer noch.
Ich kann mir das nur so erklären,
dass LinkedIn
das YouTube Video kennt
oder irgendwie das
als Werbeaccount
geflaggt hat.
Weil ansonsten
müsste das doch
schon längst weg sein.
Ich meine, dass das nicht Peter Aguilera ist
und dass er kein
Cloud Native Agile
GitOps Solution Chief Engineer Officer ist
sollte doch glaube ich
zu ziemlich jedem einleuchten, oder?
Gibt es immer noch, ja?
Ich habe leider die Zugangsdaten
hier nicht, sonst könnte ich mal nachgucken,
wer mich von euch schon geaddet hat und wer nicht.
Ja, ich wurde angeschrieben.
Jaja, ich wurde angeschrieben.
Also hier unten hast du ja noch mal
normalerweise, wenn du eingeloggt bist, hast du eine Inbox
da waren einige Nachrichten.
Ist aber schon her, ist aber schon zwei Monate
her, wo ich mich da mal eingeloggt hatte. Ich habe jetzt hier
leider die Zugangsdaten nicht.
Ich habe bestimmt, da habe ich
bestimmt hat sogar Peter Aguilera
ein paar Headhunter-Anfragen gekriegt.
So nach dem Motto
Huge Job Opportunity Frankfurt
am Main
Kannst du mir gut vorstellen.
Ok Leute, wenn ihr
gute Jobanzeigen habt, die wir uns mal angucken
sollten, dann nur her damit.
Also, die müssen wir uns noch mal
angucken, weil die will ich im nächsten Video zeigen.
Die fand ich an sich ganz cool, weil
es fängt Painschamp an, der Rest ist aber
vollkommen ok.
So, also wir gucken jetzt mal.
Ganz Deutschland,
deutschlandweit suchen wir, deutschlandweit
natürlich, deutschlandweit. Was, was sonst?
TechnikerIn
Oh, das ist aber nicht mehr korrekt.
Korrekterweise
muss das Techniker
SternchenInnen
heißen. Oder Techniker
und dann das I groß.
Weil ansonsten,
ansonsten ist triggert.
Die, die falschen Leute.
IT suchen wir.
IT.
Wir haben 16.210 passende
Jobs für sie gefunden. Das ist aber nett von euch.
Dass sie das jetzt
zufällig nur für mich
her muss. Guck mal da.
Gibt es kein MWD mehr?
Doch, doch, MWD ist ja gerade der angesagte Shit jetzt.
DevOps-Entwickler
Bei denen haben wir schon mal geguckt, bei denen waren die Stellen
anzeigen ziemlich langweilig. Da war überhaupt nichts drinnen.
Bla, bla, bla, bla.
Die übliche Geschichte. Bla, bla, bla, bla.
Langweilig. Ok.
Guck mal. Wir gucken mal ganz kurz drüber.
Was wollen die denn haben?
Du verfügst bereits über DevOps Erfahrungen
mit Tools wie Jenkins, Confluence,
Jira,
Java
und NetEye. Was ist NetEye?
NetEye ist doch garantiert
Java Monitoring oder sowas.
Siehste?
Moment, das ist was von denen.
Moment.
Warum soll ich schon Erfahrung haben mit Software,
die von ihnen hergestellt wird?
Damit hat doch niemand Erfahrung.
Es sei denn, der arbeitet schon da.
Ernsthaft? Interne Software in den
Stellenbeschreibung? Wer hat denn damit Erfahrung?
AppDynamics.
Das kenne ich. Ich kann es nicht mehr ganz zuordnen.
Das kenne ich aber. Das sagt mir was.
Ähm.
Shit.
Oracle?
MonkaS.
Was haben sie eigentlich alle immer nur
mit Oracle?
MongoDB?
Oracle VM?
Das benutzt jemand?
Okay, ich werde euch jetzt mal
massive Lizenzbedingungen von Oracle erklären.
Oracle ist nämlich,
was das angeht,
also massivstes Brain
auf dieser Welt.
Was Lizenzierung angeht.
Meine Erfahrungen mit Oracle VM
sind folgende. Oracle VM
suckt. Richtig. Aber
es macht, nee, nee,
es ist nicht VirtualBox gemeint. Es ist wirklich
Oracle VM. Das gibt es. Das gibt es.
Das ist irgendein RedHat-Abkömmling. Oracle VM.
Komm, mal gucken hier.
Okay, die meinen jetzt VirtualBox.
Es gibt ein explizites Oracle
VM Linux. Genau.
Der Mute kennt sich aus. Also,
die Sache ist nämlich folgendes.
Wenn man eine Oracle Datenbank
virtualisieren will,
dann hat Oracle lange Zeit,
ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist,
by the way, Leute. Ich sage euch einfach nur, wie es damals gewesen ist.
Hat Oracle gesagt,
ja, könnt ihr machen.
Überhaupt kein Problem. Aber ihr müsst
die Cores des Hosts
lizenzieren. Also sprich, du hast eine
ESX gekauft. Du hast eine ESX
gebaut mit 48 Kernen.
Da hast du eine VM drauf gemacht
mit 4 Kernen für deine Oracle Datenbank.
Und dann hat Oracle gesagt,
ja, lizenziere doch mal 48 Kerne
anstatt 4.
Ist eigentlich richtig
keck-weight.
Ist immer noch so. Und daraufhin hat Oracle
dann gesagt, aber,
aber wenn ihr Oracle
virtualisieren wollt, dann nehmt doch
unsere Virtualisierungslösung,
weil mit unserer
Virtualisierungslösung
da müsst ihr nur die Kerne bezahlen,
die ihr wirklich verwendet.
Also im Prinzip machen die das,
was Microsoft früher ein bisschen mit dem Internet
Explorer gemacht hat. Die nutzten so ihre Stellung
in dem Gebiet aus, um anderen Scheiß
von sich zu zählen.
So wie der Pate, genau. Also das ist die Oracle
Taktik. So, und
wir hatten
das auch ne Weile. Wir hatten das
auch ne Weile. Und Leute, das ist richtig
schlecht.
Alle Cores aller Hosts lizenziert werden.
Ja, die haben Dachschaden.
Was, ernsthaft?
Fun Fact, gibt White Paper für ESX
Da ja mit ESX
Online Migration über Cluster möglich ist,
musst du nicht nur den ganzen ESX
Host,
nicht nur den Cluster, sondern die ganze Umgebung
in einem Wii Center. Ja ey, ganz ehrlich,
ich versteh nicht, warum
es heute immer noch Leute gibt, die neue
Sachen mit Oracle machen. Diese
Scheiße hier, ganz ehrlich,
wär für mich, also wenn ich den Kram
planen müsste, was ich zum Glück nicht machen würde, wär
für mich der erste Grund, warum ich sagen würde,
schmeiß weg den Scheiß.
Aber es gibt halt noch genug
bestehenden Sachen, weil mal ganz im Ernst,
kann Oracle wirklich
irgendwas, was zwingend
notwendig ist in der heutigen Zeit,
was du nicht mit anderen Datenbanken machen kannst?
Ich mein, klar hat Oracle sicherlich
irgendwas ganz
abgedrehtes, was nur Oracle kann, aber
ähm,
gerade wenn ich irgendeine Postgres nehme oder so,
ich mein,
die meisten Sachen sind Web-Anwendungen.
Da reicht theoretisch
Theoretisch Dateien auf der
Festplatte aus als Datenbank.
SQLite
Wenn da nicht viele gleichzeitige Writes drauf
kommen. Weil viele Kunden,
weil viele Kunden auf Oracle bestehen,
ja okay, das kann sein.
Otto Jobs
Mach ich, mach ich, guck ich mir an.
Oracle Apex sagt mir nix.
Apex ist für mich das EA Battle Royale.
Okay.
Otto. Deutscher Otto Lan.
Okay,
die Seite ist schon mal gut.
Die Jobs-Seite ist schon mal
Poggers.
Aha.
Hahaha
Guck mal, die Seite lädt nur, wenn ich refreshe.
Liegt das an meinem Adblock?
Curator I
Liegt, ne, da wird überhaupt nix geblockt.
Der
blockt nix von der Seite.
Der blockt aber gar nix.
Null blockt. Okay.
Hä?
Er blockt nix, aber blockt doch.
Alles klar, sehr gut.
Nice Adon, good job.
Okay. Deine Karriere
bei Otto. Schüler,
StudentInnen,
StudierInnen,
äh,
gibt's, kann man da,
Berufserfahrene zur Seite.
Du, Otto.
Also.
Ottos Weg zur digitalen
Transformation, das ist Painschamp.
Das ist Painschamp, ich weiß nicht,
ob wir uns das geben sollen. Sekunde.
Ich bin Tim aus dem
Plattform-Team und wir gestalten die
Geschäftsmodell-Transformation von Otto.
Das bedeutet. Die, die, die was?
Und wir gestalten die
Geschäftsmodell-Transformation von Otto.
Die Geschäftsmodell-Transformation, das heißt
von Katalog zu Online, oder,
oder wie?
Das bedeutet, wir entwickeln Otto vom
Händler zur Plattform weiter. Ah.
Innerhalb unseres Teams. Das heißt, die machen
ein Marketplace, anstatt, dass sie
selbst verkaufen. Und arbeiten wir gar nicht in festen
Prozessen. Das heißt, wir haben täglich
wechselnde Aufgaben. Wir arbeiten
nicht in festen Prozessen, zu gut Deutsch. Wir haben
eigentlich keine Ahnung, was wir machen,
sagen aber, wir sind furchtbar agil.
Mal in beratender Funktion für den Vorstand
unterwegs, mal sprechen wir mit Kollegen
über einzelne Projekte, oder
setzen Teams auf, die die Transformation.
Das haben wir auch, Leute. Das haben wir jetzt
auch seit Neuestem. Ich meine,
jetzt in Corona-Zeiten, jetzt
ein bisschen weniger benutzt. Sie haben jetzt
bei uns auch manche Büros
an der Ecke. Manche Büros an der
Ecke haben sie geräumt und haben da jetzt
einfach einen Schreibtisch reingestellt
und haben gesagt, hier, das ist der
Think Tank. Das heißt, wenn du
also, du kannst nicht denken
und sobald du da reingehst,
wirst du absolut Six Head.
Bei uns sind allerdings die Glas-, also wir
haben keine Glasscheiben, wo man durchgucken kann,
was auch ganz gut ist, weil ich
kann nicht gucken, wenn ich
beobachtet werde.
Äh, nicht denken, wenn ich beobachtet werde.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Und der Think Tank,
den haben wir auch bei uns jetzt am Start.
Das ist aber auch erforderlich,
weil ansonsten Großraumbüros
am Start sind. Da kann man nicht gescheit denken.
Ohne andere Leute zu nerven.
Also, wenn man das mit mehreren macht.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was die
da drinnen gerade nicht machen?
Die denken definitiv
da gerade nicht.
Die machen irgendwelche Daily
äh, keine Ahnung,
Post-Its an die Wand kleben.
Auf die die Transformation gestalten.
Ich habe hier häufig die Möglichkeit...
So sehen keine Leute aus, die denken.
Er denkt vielleicht. Er denkt vielleicht.
Der denkt sich gerade, ich hab keinen Bock auf den Scheiß.
So sieht er aus gerade.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Was machen die?
Ich muss lesen, was auf dem...
Moment, was steht auf dem Fernseher?
Zack, Zack.
Marken-Image des Kunden.
Ah, yes. Okay.
Hat mit IT schon mal nichts zu tun. Geht mal fort.
Ne, das ist kein
Kanban-Board an der Wand. Da müsstest du mehr...
Na, wobei.
Moment, vielleicht ist das doch ein highly agile Kanban-Board.
Müssen wir mal schauen.
Aber eher nicht.
Naja, gut.
Das könnte alles sein.
Normalerweise müsstest du ja beim Kanban-Board oben verschiedene Kategorien
stehen haben und dann verschiebst du...
Also in dem Kanban-Board hängend hast du verschiedene Kategorien...
Also, verschiedene Status.
Und die...
Das müsste eigentlich schon voll mit Post-Its sein,
dass du die dann verschieben kannst.
Ein abgearbeitetes Kanban-Board.
Also du meinst sowas, was es in der Realität
in der Form so wahrscheinlich nicht geben würde.
Ne, das ist...
Ich glaube, das ist ehrlich gesagt, wenn man mal genau
sich überlegt, nichts von beidem.
Sondern das ist was
einfach dahingestellt für Werbezwecke
für das Video.
Jaja, guck ich mir gleich an.
A91202
Ist das irgendein Hex-Code oder so?
Oder ist das
random Face-Roll über die Tastatur?
Ich habe hier häufig die Möglichkeit bekommen,
Ideen, die ich hatte, auch wirklich in die Tat
umzusetzen. Und so sind schon viele...
Was, was, was? Agenda?
Moment, ich will wissen, was jemand...
Ah!
Werner, Werner Otto.
Zitate?
A...
Agentur oder sowas?
Gesch.
Ben und Gesch.
Agenda?
Ah, das heißt Agenda.
Werner-Otto-Zitate.
Bert und Gesch.
Aber man weiß es nicht.
Ist auch egal.
Wo Kunden das Ganze erleben konnten, uns Feedback geben konnten.
Und das hat mich auch schon wahnsinnig stolz gemacht.
Die Welt und die Technologie
ändert sich täglich.
Und mein Anspruch ist es, dass wir mit Otto
in fünf Jahren ein Unternehmen sind,
das diese veränderten Technologien
und Lösungen so einsetzen kann,
dass für unsere Kunden ein tolles Erlebnis entsteht.
A...
Ha.
Alles klar.
Oder auch nicht.
So, was haben sie denn hier zu bieten im IT-Bereich?
New Work.
Die Vision ist ein flexibles
und vernetztes Arbeiten,
das durch eine aktive
und eigenverantwortliche Selbstgestaltung
der Arbeitsorganisation
sowie ein übergreifendes Arbeiten geprägt ist.
Social Spaces Desk Sharing.
Gibt es wirklich Leute,
die Desk Sharing mögen?
Think Tanks fördern das kollaborative Arbeiten.
Ja, super agile,
moderne, junge, dynamische Leute
mögen wahrscheinlich Desk Sharing.
Wisst ihr, es gibt ja...
Ich könnte keinen handwerklichen Beruf
ausüben.
Das ist nicht so meine Welt.
Aber eine Sache mag ich
bei Handwerkern.
Da gilt das ja schon quasi
fast als...
Ja,
fast schon so schlimm,
als wäre er mit der eigenen Frau fremd gegangen,
wenn einer den
Werkzeugwagen
des anderen anfasst.
So.
Und das finde ich,
ehrlich gesagt,
bei den Skeptischen und Arbeitsplätzen
eh ganz gut,
wenn mein Zeug keiner angreift.
Die sollen einfach alle die Finger weglassen
und gut ist.
Okay, wo gibt's denn jetzt hier die...
Oh, jetzt hier unten.
Jobs für Berufserfahrene.
Senior Project Manager.
Gut, das ist definitiv nix für uns.
Wir setzen bei...
Was?
Wari schreibt, wir setzen bei uns in der Arbeit
mobile Arbeitsplätze um.
Also sprich,
wir haben nur noch ein Notebook auf der Arbeit,
das kann man theoretisch überall einklipsen.
Das haben wir aber schon seit 3-4 Jahren so
und ich hab das vielleicht 2 mal gemacht.
Und im Prinzip ist jeder da hocken geblieben,
wo er vorher auch hocken geblieben ist.
Das ist richtig schlimm.
Guck ich mir gleich an.
Jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal Otto an
und danach gucken wir uns das hier an.
Das sollte ich mir nämlich laut Chat
auch anschauen.
Muss mir das mal kurz hier...
Wo war deutscher Otto? Da.
Mal markieren.
Bei uns gibt es immer
ein Wettrennen um die Plätze mit geiler Aussicht.
Hm.
Ne, bei uns nicht.
Bei uns nicht.
Bei uns sitzt jeder dort, wo er sonst aussitzt.
Gut, jetzt aktuell sitzt eh keiner da,
sondern sind alle daheim.
Ich weiß nicht, vielleicht nehme ich morgen schon auf,
wenn wir heute viele gute Sachen finden.
Es hat jeder Arbeitsplatz
noch einen, noch einen
curved, was ist das?
30 Zoll oder so.
Kannst du dich halt überall mit dem Notebook einstecken.
Okay, was haben die denn bei Otto zu bieten?
Controller.
Für mich ist ein Controller
was, was ich in einen PCE-Express-Slot stecke.
Aber die verstehen
da wahrscheinlich was anderes drunter.
IT-Business-Analyst-Projekt.
Kann man das filtern?
Das ganze BWL-Zeug
juckt mich nicht.
Tätigkeitsfeld, IT.
Jawoll.
Hamburg, ja
meinetwegen.
Ah hier, jetzt haben wir es.
Interne Buchhaltung.
Irgendwas muss er ja kontrollieren.
Wenn man Hamburg weg macht?
Ah, das gibt man Hamburg.
Okay, Business-Analyst,
Software-Developer,
Java, Business to Business Accounting
und Payment.
Okay, das ist das halt, was die gesagt haben.
Ein Senior DevOps, das ist wie gemacht
für mich, das gucken wir uns gleich an.
Business-Analyst, Business-Analyst,
Technical Design Lead,
Software-Developer,
Java, Specialist Linux
Automatisierung, Plattform DevOps
Services. Ah, exquisite.
Boah, die haben aber ganz schön viel.
Solr,
Suchindex-Zeug.
Search Engineer, da ist er.
Endlich.
Agile Master.
Das interessiert mich,
was man als agiler Meister macht.
Das ist wie
gemacht für mich, ja.
Agile Master.
Den gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Teamaufbau, Entwicklung und Begleitung.
Hört sich ein bisschen an wie Sterbehilfe.
Von der
Aufmachung, ja.
Teamentwicklung und Begleitung.
Okay, Agile Master.
Das kann man doch nicht mal
lesen.
Als Agile Master
Team. Was?
Der Satz
ergibt doch schon keinen Sinn.
Als Agile Master
Team organisieren und
begleiten wir den... Achso!
Ah, das ist das Team, wo du dann reinkommst.
Also, das ist ein Team von agilen
Meistern.
Okay. Begleiten wir den
Aufbau und die Weiterbildung unserer
cross-funktionalen Produktentwicklungsteams
in der Otto-Logistik.
Wir sehen uns dabei in der
bla bla bla.
Eigenverantwortliche Produktentwicklung zur Führung der
Team-Event.
Wir sind dabei, die
Team-Event zu unterstützen, dass die Teams
übergreifend in Otto-Wert strömen.
Mehr Wert für unsere Kundin.
Was genau macht ihr?
Was sagt uns das? Ich versteh's wirklich nicht.
Was machen die?
Also, ich glaube, die hätten keine zwei
weniger aussagekräftigen Sätze
reinschreiben können für die Erklärung, was sie
denn machen.
Das sind Leute, die sich Team-Events ausdenken.
Dafür brauchst du doch
mehr.
Okay, vielleicht machen die so
Dinger in diese Richtung.
Die halten den Platz warm den ganzen Tag.
Für uns ist ein Framework
Was für uns ist ein Framework?
Wie Scrum oder Kanban.
Na endlich mal. Jetzt wird's agil.
Ob die auch Save und ITIL machen?
Was meint ihr?
Also ich persönlich bin ja eher Fan von
Save, ITIL und T-Shape Teams.
Scrum und Kanban ist aber auch okay.
Okay, also weiter.
Für uns ist ein Framework wie Scrum oder Kanban
nicht vorgeschriebenes Dogma, sondern ein Mittel zum Zweck.
Hey, das finde ich gut.
Das machen
viel zu viele so nach dem Motto
in irgendeinem ITIL
Handbuch steht drin, man muss das so machen.
Also müssen wir das auch so machen.
Ob das zur Firma passt oder nicht.
Ein klassischer Bullshit-Shop.
Ja, so liest sich das für mich auch.
Du sprichst in fremden Zungen.
Ich weiß ja auch nicht, was ich da ausspreche.
Okay, wir verwenden Methoden
so, wie sie uns entsprechend hilfreich erscheinen.
Das finde ich aber gut.
Mit dem Ziel, Wirksamkeiten der Produktentwicklung
zu schaffen. Was sie genau machen, verstehe ich aber
immer noch nicht. Wir arbeiten
Wir gucken uns gleich an, was man dafür braucht.
Wir arbeiten im Agile Master Team
an unserem
Kompetenzaufbau, gemäß
unserer Stärken und der Bedürfnisse
Okay, Leute.
Was?
Ich verstehe
die Worte,
aber ich verstehe den Sinn nicht.
Das ist ungefähr so, wie wenn
ihr zuhört, der einen Vortrag hält
über
Quantenphysik oder so
und ihr versteht manche Worte
und denkt euch, okay, das ist ein richtig gültiger
deutscher Satz, aber ihr versteht einfach nicht, was er
sagen will.
Offenen Diskurs, Konfliktkultur
Da wir gemeinsam lernen,
konnte ich verbessern werden.
Ist eine offene Konfliktkultur
was Gutes?
Eine offene Konfliktkultur ist doch
Alter, ich schau dir aufs Maul. Ja, lass draußen um 12
treffen. Das wäre eine offene
Konfliktkultur.
Ich glaube, die meinen das aber anders.
Das bringt der Job.
1 vs 1 Rust, 360 no scope only.
Arbeit
in und mit dem Produkt
Mentoring
Ach, hier kommen wir zum
Moment, ich denke,
ich denke, man
ist Agile Master.
Warum muss ich, wie kann ich denn Agile
Master mentoren und coachen,
wenn ich selbst Agile Master bin?
Coache ich mich selbst, oder wie?
Man ist dann quasi der Master der Agile
Masters, oder wie?
Was ein Bullshit.
Irgendjemand hat eben geschrieben, Bullshit Shop im
Chat, genau so liest sich das, ey.
Man ist dann quasi
Senior Agile Master.
Was ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
Okay, was macht
man da? Erfahrung im Teamaufbau.
Okay, dann
die machen Team-Events, ja.
Man darf
nicht messen, ey, das ist ganz böse.
Erfahrung in der Moderation
unterschiedlicher Meeting- und Workshop-Formate.
Ausgeprägte Kommunikations-
Skills und Bereitschaft.
Agile Methoden und Frameworks.
Na, da bin ich ja der aller agilste.
Ich hab
wirklich keine Ahnung, was die machen.
Ich, mal ganz im Ernst, ich
glaube, diese Stellenanzeige
ist aber von jemandem geschrieben, der auch nicht weiß,
was die machen.
Weil ansonsten wird mir der
vielleicht irgendwas erkennen, was sie denn machen.
Nice to have.
Ausgeprägt
diese Kenntnisse und Erfahrungen zur Feedback,
zu Feedback-Methoden und dem
Etablieren einer Feedback-Kultur.
Feedback-Kultur heißt so viel wie,
ähm,
dein Change hat's kaputt gemacht, du suckst.
Oder?
Oder was?
Erfahrung zu
Skalierungsansätzen und
Wertstrombetrachtung.
Das ist zu, zu Six Head.
Alter.
Also wir skalieren prinzipiell
eh nur diagonal.
Ich glaub, wisst ihr was?
Ich glaube, mit so einem Satz könnte ich da wahrscheinlich
echt punkten, wenn ich das in der Bewerbung
schreibe. Ich sehe, sie sind
auf der Suche nach, äh, erfahrenen
Skalierungsexperten.
Könnte man, könnte man anfangen.
Ja, irgendwie.
Ich bin erfahrener
Skalierungsexperte.
Meine Spezialität ist das
Diagonalskalieren.
Ich würd mich ja echt gerne einfach nur mal
so aus Scheiß und mit Fake-Namen
bei sowas bewerben
und einfach den größten
Stuss reinschreiben, der mir so einfällt
und mal gucken, was als Antwort kommt.
Do it.
Das machen wir. Ich schreib mir das,
das machen wir.
Das war mal im Stream. Wir schreiben im Stream die Bewerbung.
Da brauchen wir noch einen guten,
aber nicht, dass, nicht, dass das auffällt, ne?
Ähm.
Was schieben wir denen?
Ich weiß, es ist ja nicht verboten,
irgendwie mit Fake-Sachen sich zu bewerben.
Aber der Chat muss mir da ein bisschen
helfen.
Der Chat muss mir ein bisschen helfen, ja.
Erfahrung in einer
Lateralen Führ- Was, was ist
Lateral?
Seitlich
die Seite betreffend
von der Seite ausgehend.
Okay, Erfahrung in
einer von der Seite ausgehenden
Führungsrolle,
sowie in der agilen Softwareentwicklung.
Was ist denn eine von der Seite ausgehenden
Führungsrolle? Also quasi,
man macht eigentlich nur so,
man macht gar, man macht nichts direkt,
sondern
man, man
so von der Seitenlinie, wie der, wie der,
wie der Trainer oder
ein wertschätzendes
Arbeitsumfeld, Expertin
in Know-How.
Meditiere in unsere
Meditations-
Meditiere,
alles klar.
Triff deine Kollegin in unseren
Social Spaces.
Zieh dich in unsere
Bibliothek zurück. WLAN auf dem ganzen
Campus und New Work
machen es möglich.
WLAN?
Warum, warum eigentlich Campus?
Das ist kein-
Ist Campus nicht immer
irgendeine Uni eigentlich?
Ja.
Das hat doch mit Campus überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Das ist, das ist, wenn Otto Google
werden will, glaube ich. Da kommt sowas
raus.
Noch mehr. Sie bieten noch mehr Leute.
Noch mehr. Es hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Mitarbeiterrabatt.
Flexible
Arbeitszeiten, Gleichzeiten,
HVV. Okay, das ist, das ist Hamburger
Verkehrsverbund oder so.
Oh, guck mal, du kannst auch so ein paar
Sachen machen. Du kannst Geld von Otto bekommen
und kannst dann wieder bei Otto damit bestellen.
Exquisite.
30 Urlaubstage. Okay, das ist nicht gesetzlich
vorgeschrieben, ist aber ziemlich Standard
mittlerweile. Fitness und Gesundheit.
Familie und Job. Ja, was soll das jetzt bedeuten?
Familie und Job.
Da müsst ihr schon konkret werden.
Mobiles Arbeiten. Das ist gut.
Gerade in der heutigen Zeit ist wichtig, dass sowas
dasteht. Weiterbildung.
Cross-funktionale Projekte. Ich glaube nicht, dass
das ein Benefit für mich ist.
Software Development bei Otto. Das muss ich mir
anmerken. Dann ist gut mit Otto. Ich sag's euch.
Reicht dann.
Das Campusleben. Die meinen es echt ernst,
ne?
Das ist keine Uni, Leute.
Das ist ein Arbeitsplatz.
Ganz normaler Arbeitsplatz. Schuster?
Die haben wirklich nen Schuster.
Krass.
Warum
bestellst du denn nicht einfach bei Otto neue Schuhe?
Bewirb dich als Schuhe.
Schuster suchen sie ja nicht.
Aber vielleicht, vielleicht ist man so
agil. Die Leute sind so agil, die können
doch einfach mit Schustern lernen.
Social Spaces.
Das
Collaborate.
Essensangebot. Fuhrpark.
Ja, okay. Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht,
wenn man der Autofahrer ist. Paketshop.
Das ist praktisch. Das ist tatsächlich echt
praktisch. Wobei ich dafür
wenig, wenig
Verwendungszweck hab, weil bei uns um die Ecke in Frankfurt
ist so ein Amazon-Paketshop. Du kannst direkt
dein Zeug abholen. Reinigung. Das ist auch nicht
verkehrt. So wahnsinnig geil
und bequem sieht das jetzt nicht aus, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Leute, jetzt wisst
ihr auch, warum die diese Thinktanks haben.
Du hast keine Ruhe. Guck mal, das ist
Großraumbüro.
Großraumbüro, wo du dich nicht konzentrieren kannst.
Und hier sitzt wahrscheinlich keiner,
weil sonst der Chef durchläuft und sagt
Wird hier gearbeitet oder geschwätzt?
Ah, yes. Sieht gut aus.
Kantine ist echt ein Vorteil für mich.
Ohne Scheiß. Kantine ist beste.
Okay.
Als nächstes, als nächstes
kommt der Kickertisch. Der darf auch
nicht fehlen für alle, die meinen, sie wollen agil
sein.
Ich wusste es, Alter.
Der Klassiker.
Als nächstes kommt der Kickertisch.
Was hängt denn da an der Wand?
Was ist das?
Zack.
Was hängt denn da an der Wand?
Warum kann ich das Bild nicht aufmachen?
Inspect Source.
Javascript Slider.
Was ist denn das?
Luftbefeuchter oder irgendwie sowas.
Dart?
Das soll ein Dart
sein, oder?
Ach, ein elektronisches Dart. Das kann tatsächlich sein.
Dart.
Hat Marcel Skorpion
jetzt nicht einen Dart Channel?
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich jetzt da drauf komme, aber
irgendwie ist mir das gerade beim Thema Dart eingefallen.
Marcel Skorpion.
Prostitution.
Paintschamplieder von früher.
Kennt keiner mehr.
Das war irgendwie
der Diss-Track damals.
Kickertisch.
Okay, ähm.
Äußerst unbequeme Bänke.
Die, die, die,
die sehen, das ist ja überhaupt
kein Fake-Lachen von beiden.
Das ist, das ist legit
echtes Lachen. So sieht das immer so aus,
wenn ich, wenn ich wirklich glücklich bin und lache.
Ja?
Gerade bei ihr sieht das sehr natürlich aus, das Lachen.
So, was haben wir denn
sonst noch? Das ist tatsächlich die einzige Bank.
Guck mal, die sind super agil
hier.
Ist das eine Sauna?
Oder was soll das? Ach nee, das ist der
Meditationsraum.
Das ist der Meditationsraum, hä?
Ja, ich finde auch optisch
ist das echt alles sehr schick gemacht.
Die Sache ist nur die, wahrscheinlich wird es nicht so
aussehen. Das haben die alles so
super belichtet und gemacht
für den, für den Fotograf-Stelzer.
Letztendlich sieht man aber auch immer das gleiche,
was heißt, wahrscheinlich wird das gar nicht
so groß sein.
Oh, hier sind sie agil. Hier sind sie
richtig agil. Und der Kerl hier erstmal
mit, ich würde sagen, ist das
ein Ubuntu mit Visual Studio Code? Nee, das ist
kein Ubuntu, das ist ein Windows 10 mit
Visual Studio Code, würde ich sagen.
Ja, okay, der Chat gibt mir recht.
Perfekt.
Sieht halt alles genauso gefaked aus wie ein Katalog.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hatte, glaube ich, die letzten
15 Jahre kein Auto-Katalog mehr. Outlook!
Painschamp.
Gehs mal fort.
Die chatten gerade miteinander,
guck. Die sind so
agil, die sitzen im gleichen Raum und chatten
miteinander.
Oh ja.
Oh, sieht schon nicht schlecht aus.
Ah, das ist der Meditationsraum.
Exquisite.
Oh, nice.
Also, allein schon für
PepoFett würde ich es mir mal
angucken, ja.
Und nachdem man mobil arbeiten kann,
kann man doch sicherlich auch sich einfach
den ganzen Tag in die Cafeteria setzen, oder?
Ich meine, wenn man so
agil, mobil und diagonal skaliert,
24-7 Arbeitsplatz in der Kantine,
würde ich sagen.
Einfach morgens direkt rein in
die Kantine, in die
Ecke setzen, noise cancelling Kopfhörer auf,
und ab geht der
Hackerman.
Ich skaliere dann sogar meinen Bauchumfang, ja.
Diagonal.
So, weiter.
Noch mehr Kantine.
Äh.
Ist das zum Essen?
Oder ist das Verzierung?
Ich würde sagen, das ist so Basilikum
zum Essen oder sowas.
Oregano.
Ja gut, also.
Oh, das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Otto.
Helping create teams.
We are all sitting in one boat.
Okay, das sieht
jetzt schon ein bisschen realistischer aus hier,
als das, was sie da vorher gezeigt haben.
Das sieht
wenigstens nach einem normalen Arbeitsplatz aus,
auch wenn hier irgendwie
gerade keiner sitzt, aber das sieht wenigstens nach einem
normalen Arbeitsplatz aus hier.
Und die sind richtig agil hier.
Reale Analysen.
Der Rest ist fake.
Hier kommt es drauf an.
Probleme, Wünsche.
User Stories, Leute.
User Stories.
Exquisite.
By the way, warum haben die eigentlich so viele Sticker?
Das macht man doch viel besser in einem Ticketsystem.
Das Video ist nur alt.
Ja, 2018.
Was ist das jetzt, Annett?
For developers at Otto.
It's so nice that you can experience
different tools and software.
I wanna be excited to go to work
every morning because I'm doing
Das sah eher aus wie, Leute, das am Tisch,
das sah eher aus wie irgendeine Speeddating
Veranstaltung gerade.
to go to work every morning because I'm doing
what I love.
We're not just in the eCommerce
websites anymore. We're really strongly
focused on creating a
Ernsthaft?
Was für Tastaturen?
Monkeys?
Marketplace
where other partners can show
their products on our website.
So sieht Desk-Sharing aus. Zwei Leute an einem Tisch.
All the Thinkpads.
...we can provide
various other value-added services
to them.
I can only do what I love if I
always feel challenged
and I always feel like learning.
I never wanna stop learning.
Jetzt haben sie zu denen gesagt,
guckt mal besonders interessiert auf
ne Notebook, ihr werdet dabei gefilmt.
You always
be self-developing and learning
more and that's what I love about it.
Genug, genug, genug Otto jetzt.
Den wollte
ich mir noch angucken, den Senior DevOp
Spezialist. Genug Otto.
Ja. Nur mal kurz drüber
scrollen, was wollen die denn?
Was wollen die denn als DevOp
Spezialist haben?
You build it, you run it, you own it.
Moment, was?
Moment, das muss ich jetzt doch mal lernen.
Manchmal
sage ich Wörter, bevor ich den Satz
gedacht habe, wozu sie gehören
und da kommen so schwachsinnige Sätze raus
wie eben.
Wir entwickeln direkt auf dem
Otto Campus. Die haben es echt mit ihrem
Campus, ne? Das hat mit
Uni doch überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Ich weiß, Google nennt das auch so, aber
das ergibt trotzdem keinen Sinn.
Ich war längere Zeit externer dort.
Das Video ist
ein Witz. Google mal Otto Passion
for Performance.
Das ist ja von 2012.
Otto kippt
SAP. Okay, SAP raus ist ja immer
nicht verkehrt.
Das Form Passion for Performance
geriet freilich zum Flop. Ja, 2013.
Wahrscheinlich
ist es heute auch nicht besser, aber sie
werden wahrscheinlich sagen, das ist ja so die Standard-Antwort, dass es
bei uns hier auf der Arbeit auch so.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit
ist es auch oft so. Ich sage, Leute,
das haben wir doch schon mal probiert und ging in die Hose.
Dann heißt es immer, ja,
Max, das war vor fünf Jahren.
Heute sind wir ganz anders aufgestellt.
Heute ist das gar kein Ding.
Meistens geht es dann aber trotzdem in die Hose.
Okay.
Payments ist einer,
was
im Spannungsfeld der Kund
innen, der Händler innen,
der Regulatorik,
und einer Vielzahl neuer Lösungen entwickelt werden.
Alle Kundinnen und Händler. Man kann
es auch echt übertreiben mit dem Sternchen-
Kram, ey.
Jeder
soll so machen, wie sie wollen.
Zur Erreichung dieses Ziel
investiert Otto in bla bla bla
durch Zusammensetzung des
Teams aus Product Owner in
Moment.
Keck wait.
Böses Analyst. Guck mal hier.
Hier sind sie selbst durcheinander gekommen.
Und
Developer innen ist Fachwissen
ebenso vorhanden wie IT und Prozessexpertise.
Zudem werden wir durch
Agile Master unterstützt.
Die tun fast so, als weiß jeder, was das ist.
Hätten wir uns nicht die Stellenanzeige davon
angeguckt, hätten wir keine Ahnung. Und nach der
Stellenanzeige sind wir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht schlauer gewesen.
Okay.
Jetzt kommt es drauf an. Was wollen sie an?
Bei der Gestaltung Arbeitsantag
orientieren wir uns stark an Scrum.
Die Entwicklung unserer Produkte im
Context Business to Business, Accounting
und Payment folgt dem Grundsatz
You build it, you run it, you own it.
Das heißt, ich habe es
immer für immer und ewig an
der Backe.
Doch, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf.
Das heißt, die Konzeption, die Entwicklung
und auch QA erfolgen vollständig durch unser Team.
Ja gut, das heißt
das heißt ja was anderes
als das, was da steht.
Also das, was da steht, hat mit dem
hier nichts zu tun.
Konzeption, Entwicklung und
Testen erfolgt in unserem Team. Ja, vollkommen.
Okay, aber das ist im Prinzip
das, was die hier schreiben, ist eigentlich nur
der Teil mit You build it.
Das da
ist der Teil You build it.
You run it, you own it
hat damit eigentlich nichts zu tun.
Aber Konzeption ist Bilden.
Entwickeln ist Bilden. Testen
ist im Prinzip so ein Zwischen-Zwischen
Bilden und Laufen.
You run it, you own it.
Okay, aber passt schon.
Ich meine, die werden schon wissen, was sie machen.
Scheint ja ganz gut zu flutschen mittlerweile.
Willst du Teil des Teams sein?
Wirb dich.
So, was wollen sie haben?
Ja gut, ich glaube, das ist tatsächlich
ziemlich beliebt und gar nicht schlecht.
Terraform ist echt nice.
Fargate kenne ich nicht.
Sagt mir gar nichts.
AWS stellt's.
AWS bin ich nicht so der huge expert.
Ehrlich gesagt
macht ihr keiner Cloudlösung bei.
Also bei AWS kann ich bedienen.
Google Cloud kann ich auch ein bisschen bedienen.
Azure kann ich auch halbwegs bedienen.
Aber ich würde nicht sagen, dass ich der
next level cloud native big brain bin.
Das ist aber auch schwierig,
weil die ganzen Oberflächen, sowohl von AWS
als auch von Azure, die sind so gebaut,
dass man nicht durchblickt.
Aurora Postgres.
Was ist denn Aurora Postgres?
Das kenne ich auch nicht.
Ah, das ist die Amazon.
Gibt es Sinn?
Haze.me ist Google Cloud Plattform zertifiziert.
Exquisite.
SNS.
SQS.
S3, das kenne ich wenigstens noch.
Lambda, API Gateway.
Okay, das ist alles AWS Zeug.
Cloudfront, Prometheus, Grafana.
Oh Leute, Prometheus und Grafana.
Habe ich euch schon mal gezeigt,
was ich hier für ein cooles Dashboard
für meine Heizung gebaut habe?
Da kann ich nämlich sehen,
die Wassertemperatur und den Fehlerstatus.
Ich glaube, das sollte ich mal in meine Bewerbung
da reinschreiben.
Das wäre mal eine Bewerbung wert.
Gleich das Grafana Dashboard rausholen.
Elasticsearch, GitHub Actions.
Ohne Mist, also mit dem Kram
hier kenne ich mich wirklich auch.
Okay, Elasticsearch nicht so wirklich,
aber GitHub Actions.
Prometheus, Grafana kenne ich wirklich nicht schlecht aus.
Terraform ist auch ganz gut.
Leider habe ich keinen Plan von Java und Spring Boot
AWS Ökosystem.
Bin ich jetzt auch nicht so gut drin,
aber das lernt man ja relativ schnell.
Warum wollen die,
dass du Spring Boot als DevOps Dude kannst?
Weil die ehrlich gesagt kein DevOps Dude wollen,
sondern einen Fullstack,
der komplett fullstackt.
Aber jetzt nicht so das,
was man normalerweise als Fullstack
in der Stellenanzeige drinstehen hat.
Die wollen wahrscheinlich, dass du wirklich
von der Konzeption der Anwendung
bis zum Erstellen
der Azure, äh,
AWS Resources inklusive dem
Deployment alles machst.
Also, ja.
Hahaha.
Ähm.
Du arbeitest im Pla...
Das steht doch hier.
Die Eventgesteuerte
Microservice Architektur.
Da geht ja auch allen agilen Menschen
jetzt einer drauf ab, bei dieser Kombination.
Event Sourcing nennt sich das ja immer ganz cool.
Event Sourcing,
weil es gut klingt, ne.
Ist das wahrscheinlich einfach stinknormale
Message Queue mit ein paar Java
Programmen, die, äh, da
Sachen draus lesen und reinschreiben.
Das klingt natürlich nicht so geil wie
Eventgesteuerte Microservice
Architektur. Im Prinzip
sind es ein paar Java Programme, die in eine Message Queue
Sachen rein und raus schreiben. Aber,
ist natürlich so besser.
Ähm.
Microservice Architektur gleich
Spaghetti Code. Na, nicht unbedingt, ne.
Also, von der Idee her ist es ja
bei Microservices eher so, dass die
einzelnen Dinger klein und kompakt sind,
sodass du nicht so anfällig
für Spaghetti Code bist.
Theorie und Praxis, ne,
gehen natürlich manchmal da ein bisschen auseinander,
aber von der Theorie her sollte das eigentlich
ordentlicher sein.
Am Ende sollst du auch noch die Toiletten putzen.
Na, ich erinnere nochmal dran, die haben auch
nen Schuster. Irgendeiner muss
auch die Schuhe fixen.
So, du arbeitest in einem englischsprachigen
cross-funktionalen Team.
Ok, was? Must have, must have.
Fortgeschrittene Terraform kennen sie.
Gibst Infrastructure as Code.
Ich träume in Infrastructure as Code.
Fundierte Erfahrung, ok.
Ey, das würde ich alles auf die Reihe kriegen.
Da fehlt's bei mir halt, weil wir machen
auf der Arbeit hauptsächlich Azure.
Und ich hab privat
auch nichts
mit AWS großartig gemacht bisher.
Ich meine, ich hab da nen Account,
ich hab da schon mal ne VM angelegt und sowas,
aber, also privat hab ich jetzt
ab und zu mal Google verwendet.
Aber hauptsächlich für Maps
und, äh,
kleine, kleine Services und hab dann festgestellt,
der Scheiß ist ganz schön teuer,
wenn du da viele Anfragen machst.
Und auf der Arbeit eigentlich nur Azure.
Und für mich persönlich privat verwende ich eh nur
Hetzner. Wobei Hetzner
also auch das,
was Hetzner Cloud sich nennt,
kannst du nicht mit AWS und, ähm,
Azure und
Google vergleichen. Im Prinzip ist Hetzner Cloud
ja eigentlich nur ne Möglichkeit, möglichst
easy, schnell, stundenweise
abgerechnete
VMs zu erstellen.
Da steht zwar Cloud dran, hat aber mit
AWS nichts zu tun. AWS ist halt
viel mehr als VMs. AWS
und auch Azure ist ja zum größten Teil irgendwelche
fertigen Services, die du kaufen kannst
und jetzt nicht einfach nur VMs.
Übrigens, wenn ne 20 Euro
Hetzner Guthaben Code sucht,
nur für Neukunden by the way,
kann im Chat Ausrufezeichen Hetzner machen und
mit meinem Code sich nen Account erstellen und dann kriegt ihr
20 Euro Startguthaben
und mit den 20 Euro könnt ihr glaub ich nen
Triple Core Server 3-4 Monate laufen lassen.
Es ist
auf jeden Fall nicht schlecht, wenn man eh
das mal ausprobieren wollte.
Maven und Cradle sind hier nicht unbekannt. Nein, sie sind mir nicht unbekannt,
aber ich mag sie auch nicht.
Erfahrung Python und Shell Script, ja.
Shell Script, Hackerman hier, gar kein Problem.
Betriebserfahrung in Spot & Monitor, hab ich.
Gute Englischkenntnisse zur Ko...
Da muss ich wieder mal ein Oettinger Zitat
rausholen. We are all sitting in one boat.
Englisch, easy.
Easy.
Erfahrung mit GitHub
Actions, hab ich.
Erfahrung mit Event Driven Architekturen, ja gut.
In dem Fall mit
AWS Message Queue Zeug, nein, hab ich nicht.
Zwei Kantinen,
drei Kantinen, zwei Bistros, ein
Food... What the fuck?
Die wollen es aber echt wissen.
Okay.
Genug Otto.
Vmware suchen sie.
Genug Otto, alles zu hier.
So, okay, was soll ich mir jetzt noch angucken?
Das, der Chat hat gesagt, den soll ich
mir angucken. IT,
welchen denn?
Hebräisch, Kust...
Customer Support.
Englisch, Englisch
und Hebräisch.
In Bonn.
Boah, das ist immer eine Mischung, he?
Ich lese die Werbung.
Stimmt.
IT Student Assistant.
E Form Oi.
Oi.
Three Head.
IF, wie spricht, wie spricht man die überhaupt?
Aus?
I, I Foam?
I Foam?
So wie einer nicht richtig iPhone ausbrechen kann.
Die Internationale Vereinigung
der ökologischen Landbaubewegung.
Okay.
Ich sage ja auch immer, es ist nicht wirklich erforderlich,
dass man sich mit seinem Arbeitgeber
da irgendwie tiefgreifend identifiziert.
Solange die pünktlich bezahlen und man da
zufrieden ist, ist es wurscht, was die machen.
Oh, das ist ja auf Englisch.
Warum soll, warum sollte ich mir das denn
jetzt durch angucken?
It's an exciting time to join our team.
Student IT Assistant.
Äh, Max, was ist eigentlich
bei deinem Chef? Darfst du dein Gehalt liegen?
Ja, darf ich.
Habe ich auch letztens im Stream schon gemacht.
Und mache ich in einem Video auch nochmal.
Also.
Sie haben eine
Mac-based environment.
Äh.
Mac-Linux-Server, Ubuntu 16.18.20
Web-Server.
Prepare computers for new colleagues.
Okay, das ist im Prinzip, man richtet Rechner ein.
Welches ist
deine Lieblingsdistro? Desktop oder Server?
Server,
Ubuntu, Desktop, Manjaro.
Auf der Arbeit verwende ich Red Hat, aber
bin ich nicht so ein großartiger Fan von.
First Level
machen wir auch noch, alles klar.
Proactive Teamplayer.
Ja, was ist denn,
was ist denn an der Stellenanzeige?
Die Stellenanzeige sieht doch relativ normal aus.
Oder habe ich jetzt irgendwas nicht,
nicht, äh,
gesehen.
Wo steht das Gehalt? Moment.
Oh, für 1000 Euro pro Monat.
Teilzeit.
Na, kommt drauf an.
Na, Moment.
1000 Euro pro Monat heißt ja,
kommt ja drauf an, ne.
Ist die Frage, wie viele Stunden.
Hier. Äh.
Hier steht es doch.
20 Stunden die Woche.
Moment, das ist, das ist, das ist, das ist
genau Halbzeit, ne.
Das ist dann aber doch ein bisschen wenig.
Das ist dann doch ein bisschen wenig.
Leute, wie ist das so?
Ich habe von Studentenjobs keine Ahnung.
Sagt mal,
ist das gut oder nicht gut?
Ja, versteuern musst du es ja immer.
In Frankfurt kriegst du dafür
einen Döner.
Es gibt aber große Döner.
Okay, also anscheinend so ganz,
ganz okay,
eher, eher nicht so toll.
Eher auf der niedrigen Seite.
Also niedrig bis okay.
Okay, verstehe.
Naja.
Ja, so, aber so schlimm
ist die Stellenanzeige doch jetzt gar nicht.
Ja, du musst noch versteuern.
Salesforce, Igitt.
Okay, next.
Linux Consultant.
Das sollte ich mir auch noch angucken.
Hat jemand geschrieben, ne.
Linux Consultant MWD.
Standort Fulda. Ey, das kann ich so.
So weit weg.
Arbeitsbereiche.
Beratung und Implementierung.
Einstieg als Linux Consultant.
Startdatum.
Sofort. Arbeitszeit. Vollzeit.
Also, als Consultant ist er schon mal wieder richtig
Painschamp.
Also das heißt, die suchen jemanden,
der sich auskennt mit Linux.
Die suchen einen, den sie
verschachern können, oder?
Moose Hair Underwear.
Nice Prime Subscription.
Huge Sub.
IQ++ für den Chat.
Beratung, Implementierung,
Konfiguration und Integration einer
IT-Infrastrukturlösung,
die auf dem Open Source Monitoring
Nagios.
Moment, in welchem
Jahr sind wir?
Sind wir
1999, oder so?
Ne.
Wir sind tatsächlich 2021.
Also wären wir
2001 gewesen, oder
2011. 2011.
2011.
Hätte ich es mir noch
irgendwie gefallen lassen, am Rande.
Am Rande.
Aber jetzt.
Nagios wird doch noch oft
genutzt. Ja, meistens nur bei
irgendwelchen Painschamp Dingern.
Ich persönlich mag Nagios ja.
Also, wenn ihr mich fragt, ich habe immer
ein Herz für Nagios gehabt.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran,
dass ich früher mal relativ viel Nagios
selbst gemacht habe.
Konfig noch aus dem Schlaf könnte, aber
ich habe früher ziemlich viel Nagios selbst gemacht.
Ich habe ein Herz für Nagios.
Aber ansonsten, ich sehe es so gerade
also selten.
Es ist auch selten, dass es in
Stellenanzeigen
drinsteht.
Also bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es eine Mischung.
Bei uns ist das auch nicht gerade gut gelöst.
Also wir haben eine ganz wilde Mischung.
Das ist aber historisch gewachsen.
Also wir haben zum größten Teil Zabbix.
Zabbix ist aber vom Webinterface
wirklich huge Painschamp.
Und ansonsten
die modernen
super agilen
eventgesteuerten
Microservices.
Falls wir sowas haben.
Dann ist das
mit Prometheus
und Grafana
und teilweise mit
Elasticsearch und Kibana gemacht.
Als weltweites Unternehmen
von Discower nutzt Nagios sehr intensiv.
Das kenne ich da sehr genau.
Ja gut, Keeper XY, dann weiß ich ja auch
an wem du redest.
Weil ich weiß ja wo du vorher warst.
Ja gut, aber die haben wahrscheinlich dort
die Nagios Installation auch schon
20 Jahre oder so.
Ganz ehrlich, ich würde es bei uns auch verstehen,
wenn wir Nagios hätten.
Angenommen wir hätten Nagios schon im Einsatz gehabt
und hätten da 5000 Systeme drin.
Warum sollte man das ändern?
Das ist bei denen wahrscheinlich auch so.
Open Source Ticket Request System OTRS.
Ist OTRS nicht mittlerweile
End of Life?
Ich habe da doch irgendwas gelesen letztens.
Ist das nicht End of Life?
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Nee, das ist ein Ticket.
Das ist ein Ticketsystem.
Und eine
CMDB IDOIT.
Oh, das klingt nach einer Software,
die man nicht verwenden will.
Leute, Business Software mit solchen Namen
sind meistens ganz furchtbar
schrecklich.
Die Lösung für IT-Dokumentation
Oh je. Oh je.
Die 360 Grad
IT-Dokumentation.
Oh je.
So Software kenne ich, die ist
Painschamp hoch 10.
Tom hat als IT-Administrator
alle Hände voll
zu tun.
Er muss eine Vielzahl von Prozessen
in seiner Firma im Auge behalten.
Sein derzeitiges IT-Dokumentationssystem
hilft ihm...
Das hat der Chef selbst aufgenommen, oder?
Das hat der Chef selbst aufgenommen.
...
... dabei nicht wirklich.
Tatsächlich scheint es ihm nur noch mehr
Arbeit zu machen.
Wir von IDOIT sind hier, um zu helfen.
Unser IT-Dokumentationssystem hilft Tom
dabei, seine Daten in verwertbare
Informationen zu verwandeln.
Bei Fiverr eingekauft.
Das System kann ohne externe
Unterstützung installiert und an die
Bedürfnisse eines Unternehmens
angepasst werden.
Mithilfe unserer 360-Grad-Dokumentation
ähm, das ist Windows-Audi, 100 Pro.
Tom hat einen notwendigen Überblick über seine IT-Prozesse.
Wollen wir wetten?
Wollen wir wetten, das ist Windows-Audi?
... dass Informationen aus anderen Systemen
reibungslos in die Dokumentation
einfließen können.
Tom ist erstaunt, wie viel Erfahrung
in die Entwicklung des Systems eingeflossen ist.
Und doch ist IDOIT für sein mittelständisches
Unternehmen immer noch sehr
kostengünstig.
Tom ist begeistert.
Er hat jetzt eine...
Er sieht auch wahnsinnig begeistert aus.
... Dokumentation, die ihm tatsächlich hilft.
Und Tom ist nicht alleine.
Warum hat der überhaupt eine Drohne im Büro, die da rumfliegt?
Tausend Unternehmen setzen IDOIT bereits ein.
Möchten Sie Ihre IT-Dokumentation
auch vereinfachen?
Ja, aber nicht mit IDOIT.
... Ihre kostenlose Testversion.
... Atera-Werbung.
Ach, was soll ich suchen?
Danach, oder?
35.000 Views.
Idiot statt IDOIT.
Nice.
Nee, das ist
irgendwas anderes.
ByteStrikes, das musst du mir raussuchen, was du meinst.
Okay.
Ich muss jetzt suchen.
Das ist Windows-only, Leute.
Ach, du Scheiße. Ja, ja, ja.
So Software kenne ich.
Keeper XY.
Das sieht fast aus,
wie unser... Du weißt, was ich meine, oder?
Unser F
fängt mit F an und hört mit T auf.
Sieht fast genauso schlimm aus.
Das ist eine Software,
die will ich nicht benutzen.
Moment.
Ich weiß, mit was das gemacht ist.
Das ist Dings...
Oh, wie heißt dieses JavaScript-Zeug
mit diesen... Das ist so ein uraltes...
Das ist doch Browser.
Das ist doch im Browser.
Wie heißt denn dieses uralte JavaScript-Ding,
wo die Buttons so aussehen?
Äh, JS Back...
Nee, ähm, X...
XJS? Kann das sein?
Nee, das kann ja...
XJS? Gibt's sowas?
Ja, das, da ist es, glaub ich.
Nee, nee, das ist so modern.
Sieht das nicht aus.
Ich glaub, das ist XJS.
Sowas ganz... Sowas ganz altes,
hässliches.
Da sehen die Standard-Buttons so aus.
Ich glaub, das ist... Ich glaub, das ist XJS.
Richtiger Pain.
Richtiger Paints-Champ.
Wir sind bei
Stellenanzeigen, ja.
Sieht doch Proxmox auch aus.
Ja, wahrscheinlich verwenden die das Gleiche.
Okay, das ist nix, was ich...
Oh je, oh je.
Oh je, wenn ich so... Wenn ich so Software
sehe, dann krieg ich Anfälle.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Please.
Okay.
Moment. Was soll ich mal gucken?
Das da?
Oh.
Äh, MS...
Was ist denn MSP?
Most Sucking Professionals.
Microsoft Pro.
Das Mikro.
Unlimited.
Ja, das konnte Nagios auch schon unlimited.
Hahaha.
Naja, geht doch eigentlich.
Weil ich will's nicht unbedingt verwenden.
Oh.
So, hier. Also.
I do it, soll man kennen.
Und in komplexen und heterogenen
IT-Landschaften eingesetzt wird.
Alles klar.
Okay, bla bla bla.
Bla bla bla.
Implementierung und Kundensupport
vor Ort. Okay.
Ich bin raus, Leute.
Und tschüss. Macht's gut.
Das werdet ihr nicht sehen.
Äh, diese
Kenntnisinteressen bringst du mit. Sehr gute
Niedlungskenntnisse. Okay, also.
Ja, da könnte ich schon mal hin.
Erfahrung mit Monitoring-Tools
wie Nagios. Das ist ja im Prinzip
Nagios, bloß ein bisschen moderner.
Kenne ich mich auch mit aus. Wobei ich sagen muss,
meine Nagios-Kenntnisse sind schon ganz lang her.
Aber ich denke mal, so viel hat sich da nicht getan.
Und ich komm da schnell wieder rein.
Erfahrung mit Ticketsystemen wie OTRS oder
Kix.
Was ist denn Kix?
Ticketsystem.
Boah.
Meine Güte, die haben aber schon ganz schön
den Hang zu Crap-Software hier, oder?
Warum verwendet man dann sowas?
Jetzt ist es dreckig.
Ja. Boah.
Nein.
Please. Das ist so alt, dass
ich nicht mal hoch aufgehörst
das Screen.
Warum lädt es das direkt runter? Geh sofort.
MonkaVirus.
Okay.
Das ist schon mal nix.
Du hast erste Erfahrung in SQL- und API-Schnittstellen.
Ja gut, wer hat das nicht?
Geringe Reisebereitschaft im
deutschsprachigen Raum.
Was soll denn
geringe Reisebereitschaft heißen?
Das heißt, ich habe keinen
Bock
zu reisen im deutschsprachigen Raum.
Die meinen glaube ich
eher, dass ich nicht oft reisen muss,
aber trotzdem ab und zu quasi
gezwungen werde.
So nach dem Motto. Guck dir mal das Ticketsystem
Tanz an.
Warum gibt es eigentlich so viele Ticketsysteme
und warum sind so viele davon Müll?
Okay, mal gucken, wie
das hier...
Was bin ich da sehend? Was ist das?
Oh, sogar ein Werbevideo.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich habe hier
ein Ticket vorbereitet.
Nein, ich lache nicht über den Akzent, sondern
über die Optik von dem Ding.
Bei dem wir ein Dativ-Update
installieren sollen.
Was ist das denn?
Ja meine Güte.
Wie in Tanz üblich, unsere Leistung.
Hier haben wir
zum Beispiel
3 Stunden Gebrauch.
Ach du große
Scheiße.
Wir haben die Leistungsart
Software-Installation gemacht.
Wir buchen es auf
das Ticket.
Was ist denn das für ein UI?
Gleich
fertig ab.
Okay, also um jetzt mal irgendwie
einen Vergleich zu
finden. Das sieht
schlechter aus
als
manche Open Source
GUIs,
die man unter Linux 2010
verwendet hat.
Also
Wir geben aus Technikersicht
die Zeit frei
und erstellen
die Rechnung.
Das ist wenigstens performant, hoffe ich mal.
Die Abrechnung hier über
die 3 Stunden, also in dem Fall
240 Euro,
die rät aus Tanz raus.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus
wie ein altes PHP-Forum.
Die Zeit
wurde sauber gebucht.
Innerhalb vom System
...
Gehört das auch noch dabei?
Im House One haben wir noch mehrere
Einstellungsmöglichkeiten.
...
Mehrere ...
Gehörkonten gebucht.
Ich habe von SAP
keine Ahnung, aber es bestätigt wieder
alles was ich von SAP so denke,
wenn ich das sehe.
Boah, das sieht ja grausam aus.
Das sieht
aus wie eine Settings-Page
von einem alten PHP-Forum.
Okay, wir sind mal fair,
wir gucken mal rein,
wie es aktuell aussieht.
Wir gucken mal, das war ein Video, das schon ein bisschen...
Okay, Leute, das sieht moderner aus.
Das sieht jetzt moderner aus.
Übrigens, eine Sache, die ich auch nicht verstehe, ist,
warum Ask for a Demo?
Warum habt ihr nicht einfach eine fertige Demoseite?
Ganz im Ernst, das verstehe ich nicht.
Die Hürde ist so hoch.
Überlegt euch mal, wenn ihr die Auswahl habt zwischen einem Produkt, wo es eine Demo gibt,
und ihr könnt einfach drauf gucken,
die Hürde dort anzufragen, wenn ich hier dieses Bild rumzappeln sehe,
die ist viel zu hoch.
Das ist die Mailadresse, die wollen...
Oder ist das Produkt so schlecht, dass man da kein Demo machen will?
Okay, Leute, das sieht GUI-technisch echt so aus.
Das sieht nicht schöner aus.
Das sieht immer noch genauso schlecht aus wie in dem Video.
Let's go, let's go!
Ich will einfach nur wissen, wie es aussieht.
Modules.
Service-Test.
Boah, nee, das sieht immer...
Das sieht jetzt aus wie ein Nagios.
Das sieht aus wie ein alter Nagios.
Vor allem, warum schafft man nicht mal ordentlich hochauflösende Screenshots?
Oh, Paintschamp, was ist das für Software?
Nee, das ist Outlook, oder?
Nee.
Oh, ich weiß nicht, ich will es gar nicht weitersehen.
Wer auch immer das vorgeschlagen hat, mein Beileid, wenn du damit arbeiten musst.
Guck dir mal das hier an.
Warte, ich kann mir jetzt nicht 30 Milliarden Ticketsysteme angucken.
Die meisten sind grausam.
Zylatex Self...
Das ist eine WPF-Anwendung, oder?
Das ist eine WPF-Anwendung, wo einer auf Outlook von 2005 machen wollte.
Da wollte einer Outlook aus 2005 nachmachen.
Aber Hauptsache Musterkunde 1 und 2 ist da.
Warum?
Warum benutzt man solche?
Warum benutzt man solche Software überhaupt?
Ich meine, darüber machst du doch keine Tipps.
Zeugs, Alter.
Es gibt so ollen Crap, der immer noch verwendet wird.
Das ist der Wahnsinn, ey.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn.
Such mal nach irgendwas mit SAP, haben wir uns das gerade angeguckt.
Niklas sagt, musste man mit Tanz arbeiten, hab's gehasst.
Und dann kam noch von der Chefetage der Spruch, wir tanzen hier alle.
Oh, Paintschamp.
Okay.
Also, alles klar, passt.
Du bist bei uns genau richtig, wenn du hochmotiviert, agil, da fühlen wir uns sowas von wohl, sympathisch, engagiert, empathisch und fachlich herausragend bist.
Es gibt so ein paar Sachen, die gehen oftmals nicht zusammen.
Also Leute, die besonders empathisch sind, sind meistens fachlich nicht herausragend.
Und Leute, die das hier zusammen sind, sind dann meistens nicht engagiert.
Und wenn sie das alles zusammen sind, sind sie meistens nicht sympathisch.
Ich glaube, das gibt es in Kombinationen sehr selten.
Blablabla.
Du dir eine attraktive und leistungsgerechte Vergütung wünschst.
Ja, haut mal, sagt mal, sagt mal, was Sache ist.
Du Wert auf eine ausgewogene Work-Life-Balance und ein angenehmes Klima unter Kollegen legst.
Ja, da lege ich tatsächlich Wert drauf.
Du unseren vielfältigen Entwicklungskehren...
Ja, Moment, da steht ja überhaupt nichts, warum ich wirklich...
Was ist denn jetzt wirklich der Anreiz, da hinzugehen?
Wir bieten dir Kaffee...
Aber...
Äh, das ist ja absolut nichtssagend.
What the fuck?
Das ist wirklich komplett nichtssagend, dieses Ding.
Homeoffice nach Absprache.
Flexible Arbeit, Mitarbeiter-Events.
Nein, nein.
Da überzeugt ihr mich nicht.
Damit überzeugt ihr mich nicht.
Modernes Büro inklusive Parkmöglichkeiten.
Das finde ich tatsächlich gut, dass sowas da steht.
Ist ja nicht selbstverständlich.
Okay.
Man darf kostenlos was trinken.
Gesundheitstag.
Langweilig.
Weg.
I do it.
Moment.
Haben die Jobs bei I do it?
Über uns.
Jobs.
Jawoll.
Wir bewerben uns bei I do it jetzt.
React Frontend Developer.
Moment, dieses hässliche Ding ist mit React gemacht?
Oder bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander?
Ich finde...
Es sieht nicht nach einem modernen...
React-Frontend aus, um ehrlich zu sein.
Aber okay.
Ich meine...
Klar.
Du erkennst anhand der Optik nicht, ob es mit React ist oder nicht.
Das ist mir schon klar.
Aber...
Es sieht nicht modern genug aus.
Eigentlich.
Dafür.
Na gut.
Wahrscheinlich für die Website.
Ist die mit React?
Die ist...
Nö.
Alternate?
Ach ne, die meinen nicht den Job.
Die meinen...
Irgendwas anderes.
Ne.
Das ist kein...
Das ist keine React-Anwendung, würde ich sagen.
Dann würde man das hier nicht alles sehen.
Das wäre irgendein JavaScript-Inline-Kram.
Das ist irgendwas...
Keine Ahnung.
Frontpage.
Oh guck mal, die suchen einen Full-Stack-Developer.
Das ist doch was für uns.
Zeig mal her.
Full-Stack-Developer suchen.
I do it.
Für Tanz suchen die auch welche?
Moment.
Mal kurz gucken.
Tanz sucht Jobs.
Deck.
Da müssen wir gleich nachschauen.
Unternehmen.
Jobs.
Da stand was mit Admin im Code.
Wirklich?
Das ist irgendein WordPress-Kram.
Ist das normal, dass man da auf Admin-Ordner referenziert?
WP-Admin?
Admin ist das Passwort?
Wartet mal.
Null.
Okay, das ist ja noch normal.
Admin, Admin.
Wartet mal, Admin, Admin.
Okay.
Admin.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
So würde ich es machen.
Okay.
Nein, nein, nein.
Das ist doch Spaß.
Also, ich werde mich jetzt da auch nicht...
Okay.
Ist das eigentlich normal, dass man da von außen drauf kommt?
Ist das normal, dass man eigentlich von draußen...
Sollte das nicht irgendwie gesperrt sein?
gesperrt sein, zumindest
mit irgendeiner htaccess oder so
und basic auth davor oder sonst was
also Leute, wenn das jetzt schon ein Hacker-Man ist
wenn ich von Hand
vier meistverbreitete Passwörter eingebe
dann weiß ich auch nicht, dann haben wir echt andere Probleme
vollkommen normal
ja, ok, wenn das
vollkommen normal ist, finde ich aber die Normalität
in WordPress doof
schau mal nach devops, cloudops
stellen bei
lean, oh, bei was
schau mal
devops, cloudops stellen, wie heißen
die, Moment, die kenne ich
das sagt mir irgendwas, meinst du die hier
oh, die sehen
äußerst agil aus schon
Produkte, Unternehmen
Jobs, Karriere
ja
ok, wir lassen I do it
jetzt mal in Ruhe
wir lassen I do it jetzt mal in Ruhe
und
oh
, da sind aber ganz schön viele hier am Start
ok, weiter
im
Hookit
wie sind wir denn dahin jetzt gekommen
ah, von Tanz
von Tanz sind wir
zu Hookit.de
Hookit.de gekommen
wir bei
Hook
Hack
IT
ok, was haben wir so
offene Stellen
ja, eigentlich nicht so viel
ja, eigentlich nichts Spannendes dabei
guck mal mal die Azubi Stelle
ob da
ne, das sieht alles relativ normal aus
sieht eigentlich
ich finde das sieht normal aus
so, was haben wir jetzt als nächstes
der Java Mage
was
Java Mage
also ich bin eher so der Rockstar Developer
Paid
Paid Relocation
nee, Relocation
can't wait
in der aktuellen Home Office Zeit
was für Spells hat die Java Mage Klasse?
das müssen wir echt mal für den RPG was erstellen
Obfuscating
Stealth
haben die als Spell auf jeden Fall
Garbage Collector Spell
und huge
huge RAM Auslastung
Polymorph
Polymorph haben die ja
ey, das ist gut
also
wen haben wir denn hier
Stuttgart
an der Akademie zu Remoting
jetzt wollen die auch noch Lust haben, dass wir hier so was machen, ne?
lustig sein
okay, okay
es wird Painschampig, Leute
ich sag's euch
es wird, es wird, es wird cringig
ahem
an der Akademie
Akademie
zu Remotingen
wurdest du einer der Intelligesten Java Mages
des Bärenreichs Bräuninger ausgewählt
das ist schlimm, das ist schlimm
ich krieg Bauchschmerzen, wenn ich das lese
aber jetzt nicht, weil ich lachen muss oder so
weil es Painschamp ist
dich einem besonderen und delikaten Threat zu widmen
und wie lag geht denn das?
ach du Scheiß, hör dir gar nicht mehr auf
unlängst beschädigte
eine der jüngeren Adepten
die Pipeline zur Containerstadt
Copernet
ist das schlimm
oh, das ist ja ganz, ganz schrecklich
zu allem Unheil
mit einem allzu leichtfertig gesprochenen
Continuous... oh, verdammt!
nein, ich kann es nicht lesen, Leute
es geht nicht
ich kann nicht weiterlesen, es funktioniert nicht
da hat einer zu viel Harry Potter sich angeguckt hier
und zu viele billige
Dungeons & Dragons Sessions gemacht
mit keinem gescheiten Dungeon Master dabei oder so
Harry Potter Threat...
ja, oh nein
oh je, je, je
trotz der klaren Einweisung
das ist wirklich
ok
wir überspringen den ersten Absatz mal
im Stall der Akademie
sattelst du das schnelle Ross Cradle
und
da deine Mare Maven
etwas in die Jahre gekommen ist
den schnellen Ritt nach Copernetis nicht innerhalb
eines Sprints performen kann
alles klar
die Timeline drängt
und du musst dich wirklich
Springbooten
Moment, ich lass das mal eingeblendet
das kann man für die ganze Zeit
da lassen
trotzdem bist du froh
dass dich ein Team aus treuen Mitstreitern
begleitet und du dich der wohl
größten Herausforderung als Java Mage
nicht alleine stellen musst
Skelettal der Weise
Techromancer der ersten Stunde
und Gildenmeister von
Infrastrukturs
reite zu deiner Rechten und klapp
oh meine Fresse
das ist so cringe
Full Stack Warrior
aus Leidenschaft
mit seinem legendären Breitscheu
DDoS auf dem Rücken
ich muss sagen
nachdem man das schon mal eine Weile
wenn man das jetzt eine Weile gelesen hat
dann
man gewöhnt sich dran
aber das Campen hört dann irgendwann auf
wie immer verwegen
knapp vor dir zu seiner Linken hinter
euch eine nur schwer zu
estimatende Anzahl an
Front End Archern
Scrum Dwarfs
und Masonary Clerics
während ihr das Tor der Akademie
im Stellengalopp verlasst holst du dir
eine Aufgabe nochmals gerechnet
ok hier ist jetzt
das ist die normale
was sind Masoner
ich weiß es nicht, Mason ist ein Bildsystem
ob die das meinen
ah ne das ist Mason
ok ähm
dann weiß ich nicht was es sein soll
meine Clerics sind meistens Heiler
aber das wollen sie uns glaube ich nicht
hiermit mitteilen
zusammen mit deinem Team wirkst du wertschöpfende
Zauber, erstellst, entwirfst und entwickelst
kundenzentrierte und moderne
Artefakte für eine
für einen Bereich der magischen
Handelsplattform des
Bärenreichs
ok man hat so eine grobe
Idee was du machen sollst
ich glaube das wäre der Traum
für so alle Real Life
wie heißen die Leute, LARP oder?
diese Live Action Real Life
Role Player Typen
gehabt euch wohl
seht ein mächtiger Zauberer
er steht mit dem Feuer im Bunde
da könntest du bestimmt voll punkten
mit Cape zum Vorstellungsgespräch
ja
dabei trägst du und deine Mitscheide die vollständige
Verantwortung über die Spazier-
Schau mal, Kubernetes Gedöns
Kubernetes SARS macht man
mit deinen mit
ach ich dachte mit den
hier haben sie es verpasst
hier hätten sie reinschreiben sollen mit deinen
Gitmages
das wäre doch mal was
das wäre doch mal richtig big break
Gitmages wäre viel besser gewesen
Jitmages
von
Scrum Dwarfs und Masonry Clerics
die Verantwortung
das Beschwören und Beteuren der
UX Fairies gehört dabei auch zu dein
Du verlässt die Akademie
regelmäßig und nicht auf Magie
Java Kotlin Scala
ok
äh NoSQL Gedöns
Kobanedis
Du bist ein agiler Teamplayer
Produkt Ogan
alles klar
ok
Leute wenn man da
wenn man sich da erstmal
dran gewöhnt hat ist es gar nicht mehr so Pains
Camping es ist natürlich sehr schwierig
zu erkennen was die genau
jetzt wollen aber
Moment dazu gibt es ein Video
dazu gibt es nicht wirklich
ein Video oder
Monarch S nein
The Head of Product
Oh hallo
Ich hab dich noch gar nicht erwartet
Lass mich eine Geschichte
erzählen
An der Akademie zu Remotingen
würdest du einer der
intelligentsten Java Mages
Moment das ist doch das gleiche
der liest den gleichen Kram
jetzt nochmal vor
MWD des Bärenreichs
Bräuninger ausgewählt dich einem
besonderen und delikaten Threat
zu widmen
Wir freuen uns auf dich
Ja immerhin
immerhin bleiben sie da
ziehen sie das durch
ok es ist
es ist ziemlich Pains
aber ich muss
sagen es ist wenigstens kreativ
jetzt mal
Frage an euch
mal Frage an den Chat
wir machen mal
eine Abstimmung
wir machen mal eine Abstimmung würdet ihr euch da bewerben oder nicht
bewerben
Fragezeichen ja
nein schauen wir mal
mit was verdienen die denn ihr Geld
was machen die überhaupt
das habe ich nicht gecheckt
was machen die eigentlich
Fashion und Lifestyle
das ist ein Kaufhaus
ich habe ehrlich gedacht
weil die was von Bären und Bräu
ich habe gedacht das wäre irgendwie ein Bierhersteller oder so
ok
50 50
also einige von euch spricht das anscheinend an
ok finde ich interessant
ich muss euch ehrlich sagen so schlimm finde ich das jetzt gar nicht
ich fand es am Anfang schon enorm
cringig und Pains champig
aber man gewöhnt sich dran
und es ist auf jeden Fall
kreativ
arbeiten mit
neuesten Technologien ein Team
innovative Projekte
Agile Kultur
neue Top Notch Büros
Urlaubs und Weihnachtsgeld Mitarbeiter haben
Deluxe Kantine
der Joel
den gibt es noch
finde ich cool
ach Moment das ist Stack Overflow
die haben den zwangsweise eingebaut
Joel
Splonsky
oder so
das ist ein Blogger
der ein relativ viel gelesenes
Software Entwicklungs Blog
hatte vor 10 Jahren oder so
ich habe keine Ahnung
ob das
ob es den überhaupt noch gibt
Joel
der da
das ist ein recht viel gelesenes
Blog gewesen früher
ähm
ja und er hat immer
in einem seiner Blogposts drüber geschrieben
so anhand welchen Kriterien
er so Arbeitgeber bewerten würde
aber das ist Stack Overflow
die haben das dann irgendwie aufgegriffen
Source Control One Step Build
Daily Build Bug
Bug Database
Specs Quite
Quiet Work Conditions das ist tatsächlich wichtig
das haben wir bei dem letzten nicht gehabt
äh wo war denn das bei Otto war das
Otto hat Großraumbüros und
und Krach gehabt
Best Tools That Money Can Buy
Testers
Code Screening
äh
äh Hellway ist das nicht der Flur
was ist denn
der Flur Usability Test
ist das nicht der Flur
ja
ok
Full Stack Warrior
die meinen das auch noch ernst
die haben für die andere Dinge auch so Stellenanzeigen
der
Full Stack Warrior
Kobol
MonkaS
hier haben sie den Java Mage drin
ok weg
genug
so was soll ich jetzt gucken
hier Karriere
das haben sie aber gut gemacht das die alle
blaue Sachen anhaben
außer er
er sticht da wieder voll raus
und äh ja er hat
aber die anderen haben alle so blaue Dinge an
wahrscheinlich haben die gesagt zieht euch was blaues an
für das Foto
wenn die sich so mühe geben
finden die sonst keinen mehr
ich würde das nicht als negativ interpretieren
ähm
wenn sich einer mühe gibt mit
mit den Stellenanzeigen ist doch gut
und wahrscheinlich haben die
wirklich Schwierigkeiten Leute zu finden
generell ist es schwierig
geworden Leute zu finden aktuell
und in den letzten Jahren schon
also du findest
sicherlich äh tausende
die Drucker anschließen können oder die
ein bisschen Windows klicken können
aber gute Programmierer
oder äh sagen wir mal Leute die sich mit
modernem Cloud Krempel auskennen
oder auch Linux Experten
oder sonst wo das ist
das wächst alles nicht wie Sand am Meer
oder
wie sagt man
das gibt es nicht wie Sand am Meer und das wächst
nicht wie
wie heißt der Spruch
wie wie
Melonen an den Bäumen
ne
okay great
Unkraut auf den Bäumen
ach
Bambus
da ist es dann immer es gibt hunderttausend
Sprichwörter in der
Richtung
okay was suchen die
All Departments
okay
das ist schon ziemlich unübersichtlich
oh die hat die Suche aber
die Suche aber ganz schön viel hier
Def
ja Full Stack
oh was jetzt
wenn man nach Ops sucht gibt es nicht
okay sie suchen einen Full Stack Developer
oh das ist auch alles auf Englisch
hier heute ist es
belastend heute belastend
oh die sind mal richtig modern hier
Latest Angular
das wäre jetzt für mich Paints Champ aber
ich bin auch kein Angular Fan
GraphQL richtig Poggers
TypeScript auch richtig modern
Java 11 keine Ahnung
ich habe keine Ahnung ich weiß auch nicht was Drop Wizard
ist irgendein
Web Framework für Java
oder so Kafka auch voll
angesagt das ist so Message
Message Queue Geschichte
ähm das ist nein das ist
kein Buch also wenn schon ist das
ein Autor Philosoph
aus dem frag mich nicht
19 Jahrhundert oder so
ja
gar nicht so schlecht
ähm
aber das ist eine Message Queue
oder ich glaube
sie nennen sich nicht Message Queue irgendein
Event Event Based
Event
Verteilte
Event Streaming Plattform
die mehrere Billionen Events
pro Tag verarbeiten kann
haben die
Billion falsch übersetzt
haben die Billion falsch übersetzt
weil Billion ist ja eigentlich nur Milliarde
zur Verarbeitung von Daten
strömen
ein verteiltes System das skalierbar und
fehlertolerant und somit für Big Data
Anwendungen geeignet ist das ist doch schon mal was hier
dass das verwenden die Big Brain
agilen Enabler heutzutage
also sowas
wie Event Hub in Azure
ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht sagen
wie da der Feature
Overlap ist
Overview
mir kommt das voll bekannt vor
äh
Keeper XY bist du noch da
haben wir das nicht
auf der Arbeit was von denen
mir kommt der Name so bekannt vor
Linux wie spricht man das über
überhaupt Lean
Lean
Lean IX
für was benutzt man sowas
in der Realität
also das simpelste
Beispiel für was man so eine Message Queue
verwendet ist zum Beispiel
das erste was mir einfällt sag ich jetzt einfach
zum Beispiel von Versenden
von Newslettern oder so
irgendein Typ registriert sich in
deinem Job äh nicht Job
registriert sich in deinem Shop
klickt beim registrieren an ja ich will
Newsletter oder neueste Informationen haben
so dann geht dieses
er hat sich registriert in eine Message Queue rein
und beim nächsten Durchlauf
von der ähm
von dem von dem
Job
von dem Service für
äh Newsletter zieht er sich
das raus und
verschickt deine Newsletter Asynchron
so in der
Richtung
vielleicht nicht das beste Beispiel
aber für sowas
kann man das verwenden
klingt nach MQTT ja gut ist es ja im Prinzip
auch nur dass du
du kannst mit Kafka noch viel mehr machen
das stimmt ich hab mich damit aber noch nicht im
Detail sowas wie Active MQ
genau oder sowas wie Rapid MQ gibt's
auch noch und und so und gibt's
total viel Zeug
Zero MQ wahnsinnig alles
gibt ähm du kannst
mit Kafka allerdings noch viel mehr machen ich muss
aber ehrlich sagen ich hab mich damit noch nicht großartig beschäftigt
oh
guck mal hier man muss Englisch können
German is a plus also sprich
hauptsächlich Englisch
aber die kommen mir irgendwie
die kommen mir irgendwie bekannt vor
ich bilde mir fast ein wir haben irgendwas
von denen auf der Arbeit
ach
nein wir haben nix von denen
wir haben was von Atlassian
und da ist wahrscheinlich was von denen mit drinnen
deswegen kommt mir das bekannt vor
wo sitzen die denn überhaupt
Imprint
Friedrich Ebert Allee
das ist glaub ich
Mario 64 Musik kann das sein
ne ich hätt gedacht
das ist die Wüstenmusik aber das hab ich dann
hab ichs durcheinander gebracht
ach ne das ist Mario Party
Ljubljana
Ljubljana Slovenia
in
Hyderabad
in Indien
ok die sind wirklich international am Start hier
ah wir haben schon ein paar ganz coole
Sachen gefunden
die Piraten
dann die Java Mages
habt ihr noch irgendwelche coolen Sachen die wir uns angucken müssen
ansonsten guck ich jetzt mal hier bei den üblichen Verdächtigen
Jar
Hyderabad
spricht man das aus ok
Ayayar
Moment die haben auch
die sehen auch schon alle so Pirat mäßig aus
ok
ok das wär mir jetzt doch
ein bisschen zu viel des guten
also so witzig so witzig ich die
diese Piratengeschichte finde aber
ich müsste jetzt nicht wirklich
im Teams Meeting mit ner Piratenmütze
aufsetzen äh aufsetzen
teilnehmen oder also
guckt sie hier oben ist bestimmt
zugeschaltet irgendwie aus Asien
und denkt sich alter die Deutschen haben Rad ab
der hier unten
wills richtig wissen guckt euch das mal an
Augenklappe
Riesenbad
Mütz und Headset auf
jawoll
die sitzt grad auf dem Gang oder so
ja gut was auch immer also
Jar
die leben das Thema
das muss man ihnen tatsächlich
zugute halten
die äh All Hooks
on Deck Meeting
im Prinzip All Hooks on Deck
heißt nichts anderes wie das ist irgendein
Status Meeting wo alle dran teilnehmen
na dann
du wirst bei uns nicht
glücklich wenn du vollständige und durchgängige
Prozesse wie in den
großen Konzernen erwartest
es ist ein Unterschied also es gibt
ja es gibt für mich nen guten
Mittelweg zwischen es ist alles
bis ins kleinste Detail
äh ausformuliert und
alle flippen aus wenn du dich nicht dran hältst
und wir sind komplett planlos was wir machen
also ein guter Mittelweg ist
da finde ich das Beste ja so
prinzipielle Abläufe
für Sachen die häufig vorkommen und
wo man auch ähm quasi
übergreifend gucken muss was passiert
vollkommen okay aber jeden
Furz der gelassen wird in den Prozess
zu gießen finde ich dann zu übertrieben
es gibt Freibier wirklich
tatsächlich
Obstschalen Freibier
Bällebäder nein
Bällebäder brauch ich nicht
wenn ich mich in so ein Bällebad
reinschmeiß dann sind wahrscheinlich
die Bälle weg
zu Entwicklungsumgebung bei uns gibts viel
Mac OS
Arch Linux haben die
Arch Linux
Arch by the way
und Ubuntu
ist auch dabei
Windows haben wir noch nicht
und wollen auch ungern
supporten die sind mir sofort
support sympathisch Leute
die mag ich
die können mir gestohlen bleiben mit diesem ganzen
Pirate Kram aber das
macht die mir wirklich sympathisch
Windows haben wir noch nicht und wollen
auch ungern supporten
der Satz ist zwar Fail aber
das finde ich gut Bewerbung ist raus
Instant Bewerbung
Bewerbung direkt unterwegs
Hardware
kannst du dir nach Wünschen aussuchen
die meisten von uns entwickeln mit
PAP Storm Wim und Visual
Wim Poggers
Jawoll
Die sind
richtig agil hier
Eindrücke von den Büros findest
du hier ehrlich ich finde die machen ganz gut
gar keine so schlechten Eindrücke
Irgendwie finde ich das doch echt
Ohne Scheiß so
painstampig ich das am Anfang fand
ich finde das doch jetzt echt ganz sympathisch
was die so
ok die Stühle sind
naja ok
wie zum Teufel soll man denn da arbeiten
das ist ein Raum
mit einem Tisch
das ist ein Raum mit einem Tisch oder wie
ja das ist mehr oder weniger ein Raum
mit einem Tisch
das ist eine Wohnung
mit zwei drei Räumen
und da haben die Tische und Stühle
aber hier kannst du doch nicht arbeiten
oder die gehen da nur hin um
die gehen da nur hin um Freibier zu trinken
und dann gehen sie wieder heim
virtuelles Büro jetzt machen
waren sie auch schon Games
Irgendwie finde ich die aber doch ganz sympathisch
ich weiß nicht
ihr wisst ich bin nicht so der Wahnsinnsfan von so super
familiären
Startup Dingern
also für mich ist das Arbeit und keine Familie
aber irgendwie finde ich die doch ganz sympathisch
warum ist das alles auf englisch
ah Moment
das ist nicht für Bewerber
das ist für potenzielle Kunden
ihr kleine Prinzessin
ich glaube nicht dass sie zu viel Geld haben
so Startup Dinger neigen
zumindest habe ich den Eindruck
ich kann das natürlich jetzt nicht belegen
mein Eindruck der sich da immer aufregt ist
die geben Geld für sowas aus
was sie eigentlich nicht haben
oder es brummt bei denen richtig
ok jetzt gucken wir mal
was haben die für Bewertungen
boah
ok vier Bewertungen
das ist natürlich nichtssagend
paid actors
das würde ich sagen oder
steht da was von Familie
ja
gut
bei vier Bewertungen kannst du da wirklich nichts drauf geben
aber irgendwie sind die mir doch ganz sympathisch
ich kann es jetzt nicht genau sagen warum
aber ich finde es jetzt
nach dem Anfang mit dem Pirate Team
wo ich gedacht habe das ist ja Pains Champ
finde ich die eigentlich doch ganz ok
wahrscheinlich weil sie gesagt haben sie mögen kein Windows
was ist denn Cap Terra
Pirate Ship Pricing
ich weiß nicht was das ist
Paket und Frachttransport
Make your shipping cheap
1-10 Beschäftigte
die hatten aber viel mehr
hier auf ihrer Seite
naja
hat noch jemand irgendwas cooles
was ich unbedingt zeigen muss
im nächsten Video
ja das stimmt
bei denen würde mich das nicht wundern
wenn die die Server wirklich im Keller stehen hätten
links übersehen
wenn du Rockstar Developer werden möchtest
achso das kenne ich
das habe ich schon mal gesehen
guck mal mal
was haben sie denn hier schöne Sachen für uns
ach das waren die mit NetEye
wo ich keine Ahnung hatte was es war
Sodexo Gutscheine
was ist denn Sodexo
wie so Doku
gibt es zufällig bei Twitch Jobs
gucken wir doch mal
schauen wir mal
you look great in purple
open jobs
was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen
open jobs und Internships
ist das hier quasi
ausgeschmissen werden und das nicht
ach Praktikum
das ist ein Praktikum
suchen die auch was in Deutschland
Senior Software
Developer Engineer in Berlin
suchen die was hier jawoll
Berlin
Senior Software Engineer on the IGDB
was
was für ein Ding
was ist das
ist das die Twitch Game Database
oder
habe ich noch nie gesehen
ah das ist so was wie IMDB für Games
aber gibt es da nicht schon Metacritic
man kann auch keine
ok keine Ahnung was das ist
Produce clean high quality code
tests and documentation
siehste
noch nicht mal bei Twitch
hat sich das schon rumgesprochen
gerade Twitch müsste es doch eigentlich wissen
guter Code
dokumentiert sich selbst
was wollen die alle immer mit Dokumentation schreiben
ich verstehe es überhaupt nicht
alle wollen sie immer dass man Dokumentation schreibt
viel wichtiger ist doch
dass man ordentliches Zeug programmiert
was man sofort versteht
easy einfach so programmieren
dass man es direkt versteht
und man braucht nie wieder dokumentieren
easy as fuck
easy
verstehe ich nicht
aha
oh könnte ich dann sagen
dann könnte ich mich bei Twitch
bewerben und dann sage ich
einfach
alles was mich an Twitch stört und dann gehe ich wieder
das wäre doch hier big brain move
readiness to try new things
ok
6 plus years alles klar
3 plus years
web application back end
model view controller
database management
at scale
concurrency
data modeling
distributed system fundamentals
die wollen es wissen hier
AWS na gut
AWS benutzt wer sonst
steht da wirklich was von Ruby drin
tatsächlich
ja gut
Twitch war doch mal
Moment bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander
nee Twitter
Twitter war mal Ruby on Rails
und Twitter ist jetzt Java oder Scala
also irgendwas auf
JVM Basis sind die glaube ich jetzt
die haben ja umgestellt schon vor 10 Jahren
oder so aber am Anfang war Twitter war auch
Ruby on Rails
und ich glaube Github ist
immer noch Ruby on Rails kann das
sein
Github
gibt es eigentlich einen Unterschied
gibt es eigentlich einen Unterschied zwischen
ja ja gibt es
boah ok Moment
jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen also
hier ist der Sinn du hast
dein
du hast deine
deine Datenmodels
du hast
einen Controller
du hast dein
ändern
dieser Sachen und du hast
einen View zum Anzeigen
so und beim ModelViewViewModel
geht es glaube ich darum du hast deine
du hast deine Datenobjekte
du hast einen View
also einen GUI in dem Fall
zum Beispiel ja irgendeinen
Frontend so
und dann hast du noch einen ViewModel
was da wo du quasi
also du bindest dein View nicht direkt
an das Model
also sprich das
ViewModel bereitet dein Model
soweit auf das es sich gut von dem View
verarbeiten lässt
so was auch immer
ich glaube jetzt weiß man es nachher immer noch nicht
genau
aber
also das ist so wie ich das jetzt
aus dem Kopf raus sagen würde ja
MassiveViewController
MVVM skaliert besser
ja wie gesagt diagonal
Twitter Implementation
Ruby genau
genau genau
genau Java haben sie jetzt
was ist denn
Gizzard Scala
ja ja gut das ist
immer noch Java ne
wieder so theoretische Konzepte die nur den Code aufblenden
einfach alles in die Code Behind Datei schreiben
und mit Windows Forms machen easy
das ist the way to go
Windows Forms Code Behind
so
geht das oder oder
oder gleich einfach alles in Elektron
dann braucht man sich überhaupt nichts mehr Gedanken machen
macht man einfach alles in CSS und HTML
okay das ist mir zu scary
die Musik
ja aber gut das wundert mich nicht das Twitch Leute haben will
die Amazon Sachen können
das Zeug wird ja auch
also man kann ja viel über Twitch sagen ne
aber seit der Amazon Übernahme
ist gerade was Verfügbarkeit angeht
und Gelagge und so ist schon besser geworden
Twitch war davor
dafür
davor doch schon
teilweise recht
recht oft broken
kommt immer noch vor
aber nicht mehr so oft wieder vor
waren wir schon bei Discord Jobs gucken
ne aber
das hat auch keinen Sinn da zu gucken
da ist nichts lustiges dabei
das sind ganz normale Jobanzeigen
sollte das nicht eigentlich
sollte das nicht eigentlich normal sein
ah das müssen sie nochmal
explizit hervorheben
sehen sie
an sich
ja
ich bin das ist
das ist
die
das
Fände ich viel besser als eine Du-Kultur.
Da bist du kein Programmer, da bist du ein Bro-Krammer.
Digger.
Bates-Chat, Max.
Ich sehe, der Chat mag meine Witze heute wieder richtig.
Eindeutig, eindeutig zu erkennen, ja.
Walla, fix, maback.
Genau so muss das sein.
Du-Kultur ist out, Digger-Kultur ist jetzt angesagt.
Digger-Bro.
Fühle ich.
Fühle ich, Digger.
Server down, fühle ich.
Und eine spannende Aufgabe.
Ah, okay, alles klar.
Weißt du was, Walla, wirklich.
Ich glaube, das heißt so viel wie ich schwöre, oder?
Heißt das nicht?
Ich glaube, man schreibt es übrigens auch mit V.
Heißt das nicht so viel wie ich schwöre?
Ich schwöre auf...
Das kann nicht heißen, ich schwöre auf Gott.
Ich meine, das kann doch nicht sein,
dass es...
Ein Wort gibt.
Und das heißt, ich schwöre auf Gott.
Warum brauchen wir vier Wörter dafür?
Und da heißt es einfach nur Walla.
Ach, Allah.
Ah, aha, ah, jetzt ergibt das Sinn.
Okay, anscheinend macht man das dort so oft.
In, in, keine Ahnung, arabischen Kulturkreisen.
Dass man da auf Gott schwört, dass es da schon ein eigenes Wort für gibt.
Bei uns, bei uns sagen Leute, ich schwöre auf meine Mutter.
Oder...
Was sagt man, was sagt man da eigentlich?
Leute, ich war früher, soll ich einfach mal was sagen?
Ich war früher bei den Pfadfindern.
Da musste man auch Sachen schwören.
Da musste man Sachen schwören, um, ähm...
Ein neues Halsbändchen zu kriegen.
Arbeitst du lieber auf Vertrauensarbeitszeit oder auf Stundenstunden?
Stunden, ich mach lieber Zeitabrechnung.
Da kann auch keiner ankommen mit, wie hier am Wochenende ist noch und sonst wie.
Halsbändchen, ja!
Kenn ich?
Ja.
Ähm, nein, nein, nein, nein, bei den Pfadfindern nicht.
Das hatte mit Gott nichts zu tun.
Äh, Pfadfinder-Halstuch.
Ja, genau, so Dinger hat man dann gekriegt.
So, und dann musste man, ab einem gewissen Alter durfte man dann, durfte man dann Dinger, Dinger schwören.
Und, und dann hat man ein neues Halsband gekriegt, ja.
So war das.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es überhaupt heute noch Zulauf an, an Leuten bei, bei den, bei den Pfadfindern...
...Pfadfindern gibt, ja.
Ja, da war ich früher.
Und ich weiß, ich weiß auch noch so ungefähr, was ich geschwört habe.
Allerdings nur eine Sache.
Ich hab geschwört.
Ich hab, ich hab, ich hab versprochen, hat man es ja, man hat ja nicht, nicht, nicht geschwört, hat man jetzt, ich schwöre, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Zumindest, ähm, hab ich geschworen, hab ich geschworen, dass ich, ähm, Oma, das ist kein Witz, ist richtig hängen geflieben und ich dachte, mir ist sonst nichts eingefallen, das weiß ich.
Dass ich Omas über die Straße helfe und, ähm, dass wenn ich sehe, dass einer, ich glaube, ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich es gesagt habe, dass, wenn ich irgendwie sehe, dass einer irgendwie die Natur verschmutzt, dass ich dann sage, lass das sein oder so.
Haha, kein Quake.
Ja, mal davon abgesehen, hey, ich würde heute jemand, ich würde heute wirklich einer Oma über die Straße helfen, wenn die Probleme hätte.
Heute ist es aber eher umgedreht.
Stellt euch mal vor, heute steht eine Oma an der Straße und du kommst...
...und du kommst...
Wie sieht's, wie sieht's aus, kann ich Ihnen behilflich sein?
Nein, nein, gehen Sie weg, kommen Sie mir nicht zu nah.
Die lässt sich heute gar nicht helfen.
Omas helfen Max über die Straße, ja, ja, mittlerweile, mittlerweile ist es schon so weit.
Tja, das hab ich damals, damals geschworen.
Bei den Pfadfindern, tja.
Wie das übrigens mit allen Schwüren so ist, im Prinzip passiert nichts, wenn du dich nicht dran hältst.
Also, deswegen wird ja...
...ja, auch gerade in der Politik so viel Zeug versprochen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Und am nächsten Tag weiß es keiner mehr.
Genau, das sagt die Oma dann.
Die Oma sagt dann, wenn ich frag, kann ich Ihnen, darf ich Ihnen über die Straße helfen oder kann ich Ihnen behilflich sein, sagt die Oma dann zu mir...
Fick dich weg, du Homo-Fürst.
Sonst gastriere ich dir die Eier.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch Schönes hier?
Leute, Boomer, Boomer-Zeit.
Boomer-Zeit.
Eine halbe Stunde.
Leute, habt ihr nicht noch irgendwelche lustigen Stellen anzeigen?
Ich brauche für das nächste Video noch ein paar.
Ansonsten ist nicht schlimm.
Die, die ich jetzt habe, reichen auch.
Dann suche ich mir noch eins, zwei normale.
Und was ich im nächsten Video unbedingt machen muss, ich muss mal am Anfang kurz einblenden, was die geantwortet haben.
Weil es haben zwei Leute, also zwei Unternehmen schon reagiert.
Auf diese...
Auf mich.
Also ich habe reagiert auf ihre Stellenanzeigen.
Sie haben auf mich reactet und haben gesagt, ich habe das ja alles komplett falsch verstanden.
Sportrocker im letzten Video und im ersten Video.
Wartet mal.
So Leute.
Jungs und Mädels.
Im ersten Video hat auch irgendeine Firma drauf reagiert.
Ich glaube, zeig mal her.
Scrum.
Ha.
Ja.
Da wundert...
Müssten ja die gewesen sein.
Die hier haben reagiert.
Wie heißen die?
Stack.
So.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Du wünschst dir auf Mucken statt Klappe halten.
Nice.
Das Scrum...
Ja, Confim Pro.
Confim.
Die haben auch reagiert.
Irgendwo hier.
Und auf Twitter.
Was bei Wagner Jobs soll ich gucken?
Ist Wagner...
Sind das die mit der Pizza?
Ja.
Und...
Alter, ist das lang.
Sind das die mit der Pizza?
Ach, das ist eine Marketingagentur, das ist ja langweilig.
Arbeiten bei Wagner, Wagner.
Okay, das sieht jetzt alles relativ normal aus.
Offene Stellen.
PHP-Entwickler.
Oh, das ist ja genau, das ist ja genau meins.
Oh, die wollen schon mal hier Meme-Punkte sammeln.
Nur, dass es irgendwie nur verhalten lustig ist.
PHP-Entwickler.
Oh, das sieht doch alles noch ganz normal aus.
Ganz schön trist, oder?
Ist das ein großes Büro und das war's?
Okay, ja, das ist ein großes Büro und das war's.
Das ist modern.
Aber man kann nicht gescheit arbeiten und hat keine Ruhe.
Das ist dann zwar modern, aber nervig.
Und warum haben die teilweise Anzüge an?
Ich möchte kein Anzug...
Warte, warum ist da eine Axt?
Der König bekommt die Axt.
So viele Wagner.
Ja, das sieht doch ganz normal aus.
Application-Engineer.
Meine Güte, haben die da ihre gesamte Lebenslaufgründer vom Kindergarten bis zum Startup reingeschrieben, oder?
Okay, als Application-Engineer, blablabla.
Druck- und Verpackungsunternehmer.
Verpackungsdesign.
Verpackungs...
Die haben da wirklich den ganzen Tagesablauf reingeschrieben.
Keck, wait.
Jetzt ernsthaft?
Wie sieht ein Tag als Application-Engineer aus?
Es ist 8.30 Uhr und sie machen sich auf den Weg zu ihrem Kunden.
Okay, ich bin raus, Leute.
Ich bin weg.
Du musst zu Kunden hinfahren.
Nope.
Heute ist es ein Etikettenhersteller.
Ja, das ist schön für ihn.
Ich fahr da noch ziemlich hin.
Der Kunde hat gerade ESCO-Software gekauft.
AtiosCAD.
Oder CAD.
Sprich CAD.
Was ist das?
Das sieht aus wie Windows 95, Gui.
Ist es wahrscheinlich auch.
Okay.
Und möchten sie so schnell wie möglich in Betrieb nehmen?
Ja.
Die Software ist anscheinend richtig big brain.
Die kann man nicht einfach installieren.
Da braucht man hier den Experten vom Hersteller.
Was hässliche Ribbons.
Hatten die da echt Ribbons drauf?
Äh, keine Ribbons.
Hier gibt es keine Ribbons.
Keine Ribbons hier.
Nirgends wo Ribbons, Leute.
She baited mich nicht.
Alles keine Ribbons.
Sieht aber richtig antik aus, der Kram.
So, nach einem Schnellkampf bla bla bla bla bla.
Richtig geile Experten hier.
Zukünftigen Experten.
Das Wort mögen sie.
Das.
Aber als Entwickler, Entwickler da Sachen installieren, ist auch schon komisch, ne?
Oder bist du als Application Engineer gar kein Entwickler?
Den Kunden zu helfen ist das, was ihnen an ihrer Rolle am meisten Spaß macht.
Ja.
Also da, da finde ich mich ja voll wieder drin.
Also ich gehe auch jeden Tag auf die Arbeit und denke mir.
Bin ich froh, dass ich wieder den Kunden helfen darf.
Ich helfe Kunden einfach so gerne.
Das ist, was mir an meiner Rolle am meisten Spaß macht.
Gibt es jemanden, der sowas macht?
Ich weiß nicht.
Also vielleicht.
Sie sind das Gesicht und die Stimme des Kunden innerhalb von Esko.
Ich glaube, da geht es nicht ums Programmieren.
Das heißt nur so.
Warum ist das ein Application Engineer?
Das ist eher ein.
Das ist eher einen vor Ort Sales Support Stelzmann.
Jede Application bla bla bla.
Subject Matters Experts.
Was für ein Ding.
Wer kann sich echt für alles irgendwelche beknackten Abkürzungen und Begriffe ausdenken.
Das wird wahrscheinlich intern dann auch noch abgekürzt als SME oder sowas.
Dass du auch gar nicht mehr weißt, um was es geht.
Okay.
Also was muss man denn können?
Guter Kommunikator, Flexibilität im Reisen.
Lol.
Nein.
Empathie für andere Menschen.
Guter Zuhörer.
Nein.
Deutsch und Englisch fließen oder auf Muttersprachlerniveau.
Jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen.
Gelegentlich wird von ihnen erwartet, dass die Kollegen bei der Bearbeitung von Software Support Fällen unterstützen.
Aha.
Also quasi so halb First Level noch dabei.
Entweder 2 plus Jahre Erfahrung im Bereich Structural Design für Verpackung oder Eskosoft.
Ja mal ganz im Ernst, gibt es wirklich jemand, der das hat?
Structural Design für Verpackung, so viele dürfte es da nicht geben.
Und mit Eskosoft wäre wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Naja.
Okay, es geht hier überhaupt nicht um den Entwickler.
Aber warum heißt er denn Application Engineer, wenn es mit Entwickler überhaupt gar nichts zu tun hat?
Was?
Das EO is the law ist was für ein Ding?
Okay, es hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun.
Das klingt wie ein Entwickler, ist es aber nicht.
Ja gut, dann nicht.
Veteranenstatus, das ist so ein typisches Ding, was die Amis immer reinschreiben.
Das...
Ja, das ist so ein typisches Ding, was die Amis immer reinschreiben.
Veteranenstatus ist glaube ich jetzt in Deutschland nicht so das Ding, wo irgendwie besonders dann drauf geguckt wird.
Aber bei den Amis ist das so, da steht das auch immer drin, Veteranenstatus.
Guck mal, es gibt wirklich welche, die Fachinformatiker Systemintegration suchen.
Oder ist das eine Ausbildung?
Move your future Superheld.
Oh, das fängt schon an.
Das geht schon gut los.
Das ist interessant, weil normalerweise sucht niemand einen Fachinformatiker Systemintegration.
Sondern meistens nur Leute, die das unter anderem gelernt haben, aber die Bezeichnung heißt dann anders.
Für was?
Wahrscheinlich typischer Turnschuh-Admin-Job.
Installation, Konfiguration, Betrieb, Wartung, Komplexer.
Ja, das ist wieder so eine...
Mach alles so eine Turnschuh-Admin-Job.
Ja, das ist wieder so eine Turnschuh-Admin-Geschichte.
Erstellen, Umsetzen, Dokumentieren von Richtlinien, Sicherheitsvorschriften, Zugriffsberechtigung, alles klar.
Fehleranalyse, Behebung, IT-Infrastruktur.
Okay, so ein typischer Admin für alles suchen die im Endeffekt.
Unterstützung der Anwender, Second Level Support.
Okay, was auch immer die sich darunter vorstellen.
Einweisung und Schulung der Anwender.
Ja, das ist im Prinzip eher sowas wie...
Du stellst denen einen Drucker hin und zeigst ihnen, wie man damit druckt.
Vermute ich mal, vermute ich mal.
Ich finde, manche hätten...
Manche würden gut daran tun, es nicht so hochtrabend immer zu schreiben.
Weil dann wirkt das so, als suchen die wirklich so den Experten in allen Bereichen.
Ich gehe davon aus, die meinen damit, du schließt einen Drucker an und zeigst dem Typ halt auch noch, wie man damit was druckt.
Beratung bei der Auswahl und Beschaffung von IT-Infrastruktur.
Pflege einer homogenen Umgebung.
Bestimmung aus Sophos-Firewalls und HP-Arubi-Switching-Infrastrukturen.
Okay, das ist allein schon wieder so ein Job für sich, wenn man das gut machen will.
Aber wahrscheinlich musst du da nicht mehr machen, als ab und zu mal ein paar Firewall-Regeln reinschreiben.
Bist du orange?
Warum muss ich orange sein?
Ich dachte, Hautfarbe spielt keine Rolle.
Folgende Grundlagen solltest du auf jeden Fall mitbringen.
Du hast einen abgeschlossen, ja?
Du verfügst über gute Kenntnisse in Netzwerktechnologien.
TCP, IP, Router, Switch.
Ja, danach bist du Netzwerk-Profi.
Keine Frage.
Und in Windows-Servern-Clients.
Okay, Paintschamp, da hätte ich keinen blassen Schimmer von.
Du bringst fundierte Erfahrungen im IT-Betrieb mit.
Du zählst bla bla bla.
Aber am allerwichtigsten, du passt zu uns.
Du bist teamfähig, offen, gehst positiv an eine Herausforderung heran.
Genau das suchen wir.
Wollen wir mal gucken, ob SpotRocker...
Ob die das aktualisiert haben?
Ich glaube, wir haben es hier immer noch drinnen.
Nein, es ist weg.
SpotRocker, nicht, dass sie pleite sind.
Hoffe ja nicht, ja.
Da wäre ich ja noch vielleicht mit dran schuld.
Okay, ne, die gibt es immer noch.
Die gibt es immer noch.
Pleite wegen Max.
Ja, Pleite, weil ich die Stellenanzeige geflamed habe.
Okay.
Jobs.
Ansehen auf...
Die haben das wirklich...
Die haben das wirklich rausgeschmissen, was ich da...
Gut, es könnte aber auch sein, dass die einen gefunden haben.
Moment, BILD hat auch eine Jobseite.
So BND und LKA, BKA-Stellen.
Ja, wenn du welche hast.
Ich glaube, da haben wir ganz am Anfang schon mal geguckt.
Die waren jetzt nicht so spannend.
Die waren meistens sehr oldschool geschrieben.
Und die Bezahlung sah meistens auch jetzt nicht so gut aus.
Wobei ich die Logik da noch nicht genau verstanden habe, ab wie vielen Jahren man welche Stufe bekommt und wie das da genau läuft.
Was Interamt hat welche?
Was ist denn Interamt?
Interamt?
Was?
Was für eine...
Das Stellenportal ist öffentlich...
Ach, das ist denen ihre Jobbörse quasi.
Also quasi dort, wo die ganzen Jobs drin sind.
Warum brauchen die da schon wieder was eigenes für?
Kirchen...
Oh ja, da will ich hin, sag ich ja.
Evangelische Brückenschlaggemeinde Köln flittert Stamm.
Ja, genau.
Und jetzt noch in der IT.
Ich will Kirche und IT arbeiten.
Moment, wie kann man da überhaupt suchen jetzt?
Wie suche ich denn da überhaupt nach IT jetzt?
Gar nicht, hä?
Sucht...
Sucht Text.
Und dann IT.
Ein Angebot.
Der Beauftragte für den Datenschutz der EKD.
Datenschutz für die evangelische Kirche in Deutschland.
Muss man da...
Muss man da Mitglied...
Muss man da evangelisch sein, um das machen zu können?
Also offiziell dürfen sie es nicht.
Offiziell dürfen sie es nicht.
Aber wahrscheinlich werden sie Wert darauf legen und halt sagen, es passt nicht.
Wenn du es nicht hast.
Genau, vorm Vorstellungsgespräch erstmal eine Runde beten.
Ach, guck mal.
Wir bitten um einen Hinweis in ihren Bewerbungsunterlagen, dass sie der evangelischen Kirche beziehungsweise
einer Kirche der Arbeitsgemeinschaft Christlicher Kirchengemeinde...
Es ist der Vordicht...
Darf man das?
Ist das...
Das ist bestimmt Krauzone.
ich verstehe es also ich verstehe das schon aus den ihrer sicht aber ich weiß
nicht ob man das darf gut ist mir ehrlich gesagt doch vollkommen egal dass
wir nicht machen ja man kann leider nicht technischer dienst
ich weiß nicht diesem ganzen dieses diesem ganzen amt zeug haftet einfach so
unglaublich so eine so eine staub bürokratie schicht an das liest sich
auch immer in diesen stellenanzeigen so also das wirkt alles immer so unglaublich
behäbig und oldschool und wie aus dem letzten jahrtausend einfach nur
stadtplanung netzwerk administratorinnen netzwerk administratorin die sind alles
andere als agil eingruppierung erforderlicher
verfolgt in die entgeltgruppe 11 tvl okay das ist wahrscheinlich wieder gar
nix guck mal 11 ok wenn du stufe 6 bis ist in ordnung also stufe 6 kann man kann
man kann man machen ja wann ist man an stufe 6
wie viel verdienst du ungefähr 70.000 im jahr mal 0,8 weil ich nur vier tage
arbeite dann hast du es ungefähr recht gut was ich verdiene
so wie wird man so jetzt guckt euch die seite an die sieht schon aus wie von
1995 ich meine das geht schon in ordnung je
nachdem na ja ich sage ich habe es aufgegeben dadurch durch zu blicken wie
das wie das da bezahlt wird öffentliche sachen das checke ich nicht
sie sind für die administration von netzwerk komponenten zuständig okay das
hätte ich mir gedacht als netzwerk administrator 70 kam mit
zwölf oder 13 gehälter mit 14 ich hab ich hab wirklich alles schon mit
reingerechnet deswegen sage ich aber sogar daumen
gepeilt 70 kann ja ich weiß bevor die ersten wieder ankommen würden ja mit
jobwechsel kriegst du mehr ist mir wurscht in bayern würdest du das nicht
bekommen okay so ja und weil die frage kommt was ich mache guckt euch mal an
ich habe da ein komplettes video darüber gemacht da guck mal da wenn ihr euch
angucken 14 minuten
warum auch immer border so des video schon älterweil borderlands 3 im
hintergrund mussteHis HAVE NE PORPEAK
von CO anfangen bis hin zu nach dreizehn können euch anhören
das stimmt zum größtenteil auch noch was ich da in diesem video erzählen was
ich mache
angucken schon spät ja noch in acht minuten ist es ist es ist das bett
zeit also was wollen die diese schrift art hier macht trinkt mich schon warum
muss alles was ämter machen so krass nach amt und stellt Harveyares Sack und
aussehen vielleicht stehen darauf dass es aussieht wie eine schreibmaschine oder
so wobei ich den fonds an sich in so einem editor ganz ganz ganz okay finden
würde aber die pflege erstellt sie betreuen kunden okay was wollen sie ihr
profil der führung bei einer hochschule erworbenes bachelor in der informatik
warum soll ich ein bachelor haben als netzwerk admin was in welcher welt leben
die eigentlich okay alternativ bringen sie den staatlichen abschluss eines
operativ prof das ja das ist die irk weiterbildung das ist die irk
weiterbildung die kann die irgendwie kaum einer macht kennt ihr irgendjemand
der operative professional gemacht hat bei der irk ich kenne nicht einen ach
echt da gesagt du machst das interessant ich kenne wirklich niemand der das macht
okay oder sie weisen einen langen
jährige einschläge berufsunterfahrung in der it naja okay da wenigstens ist
james teilweise sie bringen kenntnis über netzwerkprotokolle beispielsweise
tcp ip s1 p ospf was ist denn ist das spelling tree soll das spelling tree
sein spa und wie aber dass die das hintendran schreiben dann das geht
zumindest von die netzwerk richtung meint spending trees eigentlich der sache
in dem um das du dich
in der regel nicht kümmern muss mal an big brain frage für was braucht man
spanning tree was vermeidet man mit spanning tree also wofür ist das
eigentlich erfunden worden kreisel kreisende rahmen loops ja richtig der
chat der chat ist hat sich eindeutig gelohnt dass so viele leute subscribed
haben der iq des chats ist einfach richtig weit richtig weit oben
spanning tree ist dafür erfunden worden dass man schleifen in seinem
netzwerkequipment vermeidet also sprich also auf switch auf layer 2 ebene also
sprich wenn du denn wenn du den switch hast und den verbindest du mit mehr als
einem port miteinander du nimmst du nimmst zwei switche und steckst dort
quasi vier ports zusammen dann hast du ja das problem dass du nicht weißt wo du
eigentlich hin muss weil das könnte ja dann
wie auch immer
und dann schaltet spanning tree einfach alles aus so dass es nur noch einen
sinnvollen gültigen weg gibt ohne schleifen moment wo stand das
wo war ich jetzt eigentlich gerade hier so snmp ist meistens ganz nützlich für
monitoring von netzwerkequipment ospf ist ein routing protokoll
ospf benutzt du da wo du viele netze hast und die automatisch verteilen muss
dass die router wissen wo was ist also meistens ist es so
mann ist habe ich überlegt ich mach so denke bei da dasע nahv listung die
weiß nicht was ist denn eher marketing funktioniert
uspf illegal halt gegen 25 die regel ausnahmen beschädigen die regel meistens
benutzt man intern ospf und zwischen den netzen ist es ein bgp oder windspurt
da muss man sich aber dann meistens keine gedanken darüber machen weiter
dann provider handelt intern machst du meisten service früher hat man noch
drehs gemacht wie hieß das labels hieß das früher
tr recap
ein
spiel weil das ist in dem zielvesen sagte schweizer überall es ist quelque TYPE
protokoll in der richtung und dann gab es noch die cisco variante da habe ich
aber vergessen wie die heißt grip oder so zumindest heutzutage verwenden
eigentlich alle ospf grip ist auch easy das stellst du deinem router einfach ein
welche netze erkennt und fertig und drückt macht ein häkchen an und es
funktioniert kenntniswünsche aktiven das hp verwenden sowohl ok
wlan automatisierungslosen ansatz ok nice wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss
rein syntaktisch und vom vom handling her wir machen so viel pappert auf der
arbeit aber ich habe ja privat jetzt ein bisschen ansatz gemacht und auch
beispielsweise die ganze den preis champ damit automatisiert und ein paar
singen gemacht vom handling her muss ich sagen gefällt mir einfach um längen
besser als pappert und chef hat nichts mit
pappert und schaff hat nichts mit pappert und schaff hat nichts mit
pippo fett zu tun das ist eine ruby basierte automatisierungslösung glaube
verwendet kaum noch einer pappert und ansatz ist soll stack ist glaub auch
noch recht beliebt und fürs provisioning terraform skript sprachen
shell peisen bash naja gut das kommt ja mehr oder weniger aufs gleiche raus ja
ich weiß das ist noch ein bisschen älter aber in der regel ist damit heutzutage
eigentlich gemeint sie verfügen über gute deutschkennung
dass ok der ist schon vorbei da ist schon vorbei und grundkenntnisse der
englischen sprache die bereitschaft zu vor ort einsetzen in den wochen und
einsätze ist voraus
opa.de obas warum ich warum schreiben die sowas nicht dahin ganz im ernst
warum schreiben die sowas nicht direkt oben hin
die least den ganzen scheiß durch als mangel und man interessiert sich nicht
dafür. Lies den ganzen
Scheiß durch und dann siehst du, ah, und
tschüss. Wann kann man mit dem Video
rechnen? Vielleicht, vielleicht
übermorgen.
Vielleicht auch am Freitag.
Geht da was von Homeoffice?
Ach, tatsächlich.
Zum Beispiel Homeoffice.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten.
Ja, zum Beispiel Homeoffice. Na, mal
gucken, das würde mich mal interessieren. Würde mich mal interessieren,
wie die das mit Homeoffice machen wollen, wenn
vor Ort Einsätze, Wochenendeinsätze und
Rufbereitschaft, ne?
Du machst quasi Rufbereitschaft, während du Homeoffice
machst, oder wie stellen die sich das vor?
Ja.
Offenes Arbeitsklima.
Okay, es gibt auch im Prinzip, beim ehrlichsten
keine Vorteile.
Nichts, was hier steht, sind irgendwie
geile Vorteile.
Wir leben Vielfalt.
Wir freuen uns besonders über Bewerbung von
Frauen. Ja,
dann passen wir doch perfekt zusammen.
Da kann man sich doch einfach für die Bewerbung
als Frau identifizieren.
Easy Job abgreifen und danach
wieder als Mann. Das müsste man
eigentlich machen. Das ist eigentlich der
Six-Head-Move schlechthin im Jahr 2021.
Wenn, ey, das müsste man
Das müsste man echt mal
ausprobieren, ob das klappt.
Das müsste man echt mal ausprobieren, ob das klappt.
Wenn die irgendwo schreiben, Frauen werden
bevorzugt oder was auch immer, einfach nur so
just for fun. So, ja,
da bräuchte ich natürlich noch den passenden Namen. Und ihr wisst,
ihr dürft mich da nicht mehr Max
nennen, weil das ist
Deadnaming. Und das ist ganz fies
und dann ist es vorbei.
Dann ist Instant-Anzeige raus.
Da muss ich mir erst nochmal einen neuen Namen
ausdenken.
Was ist denn ein wohlklingender
Frauenname für mich?
Maxime.
Nein, nein, nein. Maximan.
Was ganz anderes.
Manuela.
Oh, Beate.
Beate. Das klingt so der Klassiker.
Der Klassiker.
Was ist denn so ein richtig
oldschool Gertrude oder sowas?
Gutruhen.
Gertrud.
Gertrud finde ich gut.
Brunhilde ist auch nicht schlecht, ja.
Aber ich glaube,
Gertrud finde ich gut.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, Gertrud wird's.
Gertrud Agile.
Muss Oma Gertrud
nicht ins Bett? Doch.
Schon zwei Minuten über der Zeit, Leute.
Fuck, jetzt vorbei.
Euer Spaß ist zu Ende.
Keck Wait.
Jetzt ist jetzt zu spät.
Jetzt vorbei.
Ausgelacht hier.
Ob es irgendjemand gibt, der nicht hosten kann?
Ach komm, wir hosten wieder.
Ist ist der Hot?
Ist mein Hot Tube Stream noch on?
Wie?
Wo ist?
Der Hot Tube Stream ist off.
Na gut, da kann ich jetzt keinen hosten.
Da kann ich jetzt keinen hosten.
Keiner on.
Was ist das?
Otter?
Nee.
YouTube hat dich rate limited.
Drecksäge.
Kid Boga.
Kid Boga ist wirklich nice.
Also wenn ich einem den Erfolg auf Twitch
wirklich komplett gönne,
auch vom Content her ist das eher.
Also der macht das unglaublich gut.
Leute, ich geh jetzt off.
Ich geh pennen.
Wir sehen uns die Tage. Bis denn.
See you.